So Leute, da sind wir.
Ich hoffe, dass es mit dem Delay funktioniert.
Ich habe nämlich heute ein bisschen Delay eingestellt für den Stream.
Damit der Stream-Snipe nicht zu krass wird.
Ob das klappt.
Aber es muss alles funktionieren mit dem...
Also ich meine, das Delay kann man eigentlich keinen Mist einstellen.
Man macht den OBS so ein Häkchen, ein paar Sekunden Delay und klickt OK.
Das war's.
Ja, geht doch nicht.
Moin, sind ja so viele Leute schon da.
Ich habe gesehen, die Leute haben hier wieder...
Ein paar Leute haben gelurkt schon im Channel, wie es losgeht.
So, jetzt müssen wir erstmal Posts machen.
Es buffert.
Buffern ist in der Regel nicht gut.
Allerdings, wenn ich mir das angucke, ich habe keine Mist-Frames und nichts...
Da scheint nichts zu lecken.
So, jetzt müssen wir noch die passende Musik finden.
Was machen wir denn heute mal für Musik an?
Was haben wir denn hier?
Epic, Powerful...
Ach du Scheiße.
Epic, Powerful, Heroic, Battle...
Epic, Battle, Music.
Was ist denn das für ein Titel?
Okay, das müssen wir jetzt anmachen.
Epic, Powerful, Heroic, Epic, Battle, Music.
Meine Güte, du hast einen Tütsch, Alter.
Okay, das machen wir jetzt mal an.
Ist das Heroic?
Man hört eigentlich kaum was, ne?
Ich finde jetzt, dass es Heroic ist.
Ja, übrigens, Battlefield geht gleich in Fullscreen.
Das ist immer, wenn man raustappt, weil es Battlefield 3 ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Okay, das ist die übliche Musik.
Quasi, ich mache Chor rein und sie ist episch.
Was auch ganz viele Film-Soundtracks in letzter Zeit verfolgen.
So, nachdem es passiert, was episch ist.
Wir wissen nicht, wie wir das ordentlich musikalisch untermalen sollen.
Ach komm, Chor rein und gut ist.
Oh, oh, oh.
So.
Ups.
Tja, das war es mit Epic Battle Music.
Ist abgekackt.
Der Browser-Tab.
So.
Ihr müsst mir gleich nochmal, ich werde das gleich posten wieder, Twitter und alles mögliche.
Ich muss nochmal selbst reinhören in meinen Stream, wie Lautstärke und so ist.
Also für mich ist die Lautstärke gut.
Ich habe jetzt Delay drin, deswegen muss ich 20 Sekunden warten.
Der Eax hostet mich, danke.
Also quasi, ich habe dich gehostet.
Du hostest mir meine Viewer quasi wieder zurück.
Das ist nice.
Ach, ich finde, Battlefield könnte man noch einen Ticken lauter machen, oder?
Battlefield könnte man, man könnte es glaube ich noch einen Ticken, Tick lauter machen.
Nicht viel.
Oh ne, jetzt ist es mir zu laut.
Battlefield braucht immer übel Sound-Fine-Tuning.
Warum spielen wir eigentlich diese Kack-Map?
Das muss weg.
Ich switch die Map gleich.
So, mal refreshen.
Auf geht's.
Ähm.
Also einen Ticken lauter mache ich es jetzt.
Och.
Das ist ein bisschen sehr laus.
Allerdings, ich mache es nur für euch lauter, nicht für mich.
Gucken wir mal, wie das so jetzt ist.
Ja, ich glaube so ist gut.
Das heißt, im Dauerfeuer bin ich immer noch lauter.
Ah, man hört's.
So ist das gut.
Nice.
Weißt du.
Darf man im Server joinen?
Ja klar, Ausrufezeichen Server.
Go, go, go.
So, dann posten wir den Krempl mal überall, dass es losgeht.
Haha, mein Win-Loss unten links, Überbleibsel von Overwatch.
War man ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich jetzt für Battlefield, aber drauf geschissen.
So, ich muss jetzt erstmal eine Runde Strem-Ankündigung posten.
Der Sibaro liegt schon auf dem Panzer rum.
Ich muss mich ab und zu mal bewegen, dass ich nicht gekickt werde von meinem eigenen Server.
Das wär's jetzt.
Twitter hat den falschen Titel.
Sag mal, ihr habt im Streamtitel Battlefield 3.
Äh, BF3 Easy Clap oder irgendwie sowas.
So ein Blödsinn müsste da drin stehen.
So.
Also ich muss sagen.
Super Epic Heroic.
Mega Battle Music oder sowas, was da angeblich laufen soll, ist es jetzt auch nicht.
Aber dann lenkt es mich wenigstens nicht so sehr ab.
So, jetzt machen wir mal was ganz Abgedrehtes.
Heute geht's ab hier, sag ich euch.
Denn ich werde es jetzt mal auf YouTube posten.
In diesem neuen Twitter für Arme auf YouTube.
Kennt, kennt, habt ihr das schon gesehen?
Gibt es, es gibt jetzt auf YouTube so ein, ein Twitter, Twitter für Arme Feature.
Hallo Sergeant Mixe.
Was bestimmt nicht Mixe.
Soll das so heißen?
Soll Mixe, äh, ich find Mixe eh besser.
Ähm.
Ja, ich poste das mal auf YouTube und dann wird's wahrscheinlich relativ voll, denk ich mal.
So, mal kurz zwischendrin bewegen.
Der Eax muss zu mir ins Team.
Wo ist er?
Ich muss erst mal hier gucken.
Sobald er gejoint ist, muss ich ihn zu mir rüberpacken.
So, Twitter.
Inhalte auf YouTube teilen.
Heute Battlefield 3 Stream.
Lull.
So.
Postet man das jetzt, kann man hier irgendein Links, vorhandenes YouTube-Video hinzufügen, nein, Umfrage hinzufügen, nein, Bild hinzufügen, nein, ich will Link hinzufügen, das muss doch abfunktionieren, oder?
Probieren wir heute Battlefield 3 Stream mit eigenem, so, aber, go, go, go, Beitrag erstellen.
Auf Twitch.
Geht das jetzt?
Ja, jetzt hat das, jetzt hat das gepostet auf YouTube.
Oder, oder wie mein Kumpel der Carsten immer sagt, das heißt nicht YouTube, Max, das heißt die YouTubee.
Ja, bitteschön.
Und wenn der Carsten sowas sagt, dann stimmt das meistens.
So.
Auf geht's.
Erstmal diese Kack-Map wegmachen, erstmal.
Moment, wo ist denn der Eax hier?
Max, was hältst du von den Patch-Notes der neuen Overwatch-Season gelesen?
Ja, sag ich gleich was zu.
Da sag ich gleich was zu.
Wo ist denn der Eax?
Ich muss den erst mal, ist der schon bei mir im Team?
Eax, bist du bei mir schon drin?
Ich hab dich grad Server-Joinen sehen.
Aber, ach hier, da, ich seh dich.
Klar.
Passt.
Okay, dann machen wir jetzt mal eine ordentliche Map und auf geht's.
Ähm, Map.
Lists, oh, Moment, Patrick, wie ging das nochmal so, äh, äh, Map-Switch, wie ging das nochmal, Map-Switch, konnte ich, aber man, wie ging, wie konnte man hier nochmal die Map switchen, ich glaube, man musste irgendwo, irgendwo gab's Map-Rotation-List, Caspian-Border-Rush, ich bin grad zu dumm, ähm, ah, hier, Map-List, ha, ich hab's.
Patrick, wie, hast du ne Ahnung, wie man Map switcht?
Ah, Next Level muss ich im Chat machen, okay.
Ah, sehr schön, auf geht's, go, go, go.
Ja, äh, es hat jemand eben gefragt nach den Overwatch-Patch-Notes, was ich dazu, also nicht Patch-Notes, zu dem, was die Entwickler gesagt haben.
Äh, Hexe, kannst du einfach, einfach reinschauen, wenn du drinne bist, im, in, auf dem Server, dann pack ich dich auf die richtige Seite.
Was haben wir denn hier, sind wir Defense? Wir sind Defense.
Äh, Server gibt's mit Ausrufezeichen, Server, wer mitspielen will, einfach reinschauen.
Allerdings, ähm, für 1-2 Leute sind Slots reserviert, wenn die mitspielen wollen, dann dürfen sie mitspielen.
Ach, Moment, du bist ja schon drin, dann mach mal, ich pack dich mal auf die andere Seite, dass das Stream-Snipe nicht so schlimm wird.
Äh, so, easy.
Ja, das dauert jetzt noch 1-2 Runden, bis, bis ich hier alles eingestellt hab, aber dann geht's los.
Ja, ich wollte was zu den Overwatch-Patch-Notes sagen, beziehungsweise zu dem, was die Entwickler gepostet haben.
Ach, da oben sitzt er schon wieder.
Was die Entwickler gepostet haben, und zwar, wer's nicht gelesen hat,
sei mir geschrieben, dass, äh, in Overwatch, das Matchmaking, also sprich dieses, dieses Performance-based Matchmaking abgeschafft werden soll.
Ihr müsst übrigens mal ein neues Squad machen.
Wie, wie konnte man in Battle... wie kommt man hier, Leaf Squad?
Wie konnte man hier nochmal ordentliche Squads aufmachen?
Äh, ging das hier, ging das in Battlefield irgendwie, neues Squad?
Ich bin da viel zu dumm für...
Ach, hier, Create Squad, Squad.
Ich hab, ich hab mal Delta aufgemacht.
Also, Eax und...
Oh!
Ja, Leute, ist ja gut, ey.
Lasst uns hier mal aus dem Squad raus.
Ja.
Ja, auf geht's.
Ja, jetzt bin ich immer noch nicht los geworden, was ich zu den Overwatch-Änderungen denke.
Ich glaube, das ist eine gute Sache, Performance-based Matchmaking abzuschaffen.
Ist einfach sinnlos.
Weil, wenn man sich vorstellt, dass, ähm, durch Performance-based Matchmaking,
auch so ein, so ein Krempel in Overwatch wie Torb-One-Tricks und Symmetra-One-Tricks und so was,
dass das quasi geblüht hat, auch auf Grandmaster, ist halt schon ein bisschen der Witz, ne?
Da ist was.
Oh, oh, oh, da fährt ein LRV.
Piss dich, piss dich, alter LRV.
Echt.
Ich hab Schiss.
Alter, lass mich doch hier mal raus.
Okay, der LRV trifft nix.
Okay, jetzt bin ich...
Aber war sowas von gereckt worden.
Wie viel FPS hast du eigentlich bei Battlefield?
Ähm, ich, ich glaube, es hat nur...
Ich glaube nur 144 hab ich...
Moment, hab ich...
Ich hab V-Sync eingestellt, ne?
Das muss weg.
V-Sync.
Aus.
Ach stimmt, das war ja das Battlefield, wo man in keine Settings reingehen konnte.
Wirst du in nächster Zeit wieder einen eigenen Battlefield 3 Server betreiben?
Das ist mein eigener Battlefield 3 Server hier.
Ausrufezeichen Server.
Dann findest du die...
Die Uhr...
Für's Battlelog, wo du drauf musst.
Einfach Ausrufezeichen Server.
Hab ich vorhin aktualisiert.
Und jetzt muss ich mich erst mal wieder an das Game gewöhnen, ne?
Wir brauchen auch was gegen diesen komischen LRV.
Naja, wenn das Ganze zu unbalanced ist, behalte ich mir natürlich vor...
...das hier umzusortieren.
Nee, man stirbt nicht, wenn man ins Wasser springt.
Man stirbt nur, wenn man von zu hoch ins Wasser springt.
Das Battlefield-Physics.
Ist echter als im Echt.
Kann das sein, dass wir ganz schön auf den Sack kriegen?
Und nicht zu sagen, wir werden geschreckt?
Alter, der LRV! Der LRV!
Oh. Uuuuh.
Voll in die Fresse geschossen.
Genau, und...
...der...
...li...
...ron...
...digi...
Ich weiß nicht, wie man das ausspricht.
Schreibt...
...schreibt genau das, was der Entwickler auch geschrieben hat im Forum.
Das ist bloß ab Diamond-Rank so.
Warum auch immer.
Weil Blizzard-Logik.
Chat wird wieder zum Flamen genutzt, so sonst nix.
Was auch sonst, ne?
Man, Battlefield...
...ist ja wieder geschleipt und...
...was machen wir hier eigentlich?
Wir sind so...
...so mitten im Gegnerspawn...
...obwohl wir eigentlich da hinten irgendwo defenden müssen.
Aber, mein Gott, solange die Gegner...
...wissen, was wir tun.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Da kommt ein LRV.
Headglitch.
Headglitch is real.
Ich hab Schiss.
Wie, der ist nicht gestorben?
Ich muss, ich muss weg.
Ich muss weg.
Auf, kommt her.
Kommt her, Leute.
Kommt her.
Easy Clap.
Ah!
Hinter mir!
Nein!
Scheiße.
Ja, also, wenn ihr Fragen habt, add Wubblos im Chat, dass ich...
...dann ist das rot...
...rot gehighlighted.
So, erstmal wieder an das Game gewöhnen.
Ewig nicht mehr gespielt.
Das letzte Mal hier im Stream.
Ruf dich.
Und das ist jetzt auch schon wieder...
Wie lange ist das...
Wie lange ist der letzte Battlefield-Stream her?
Drei Monate?
Zwei Mon...
Na, so lange nicht.
Zwei Monate?
Also, ist schon ein bisschen her.
Bisschen diesen komischen...
Bisschen LRV-Kack-Recken.
Grenade!
Ah!
Das geht mir auf den Sack.
Ich muss respawnen.
Nein, Moment.
Mit H wechselt man nur in Overwatch.
Die H wechselt man nur in Overwatch.
Wie wechselt man hier nochmal, Helden?
Ich glaube es geht nur hier in diesem...
athrex?
Ich muss weg.
Der Eax rockt's weg hier.
Der Forasius und mich.
Uh!
Direkt wegkannnen.
Spielst du auf Xbox?
Auf der aktuellen Xbox One?
Ich habe eine.
Spe...
Ich quasi.
nix weil es gibt nichts was gibt es also ganz ernsthaft moment wir haben hier
zweimal spot spot cover das ist nicht so optimal also ernsthaft ist es jetzt ich
will ich will die plattform nicht flame oder so ich war ganz realistisch
gefragt gibt es irgendwas wofür man sich die xbox one unbedingt kaufen muss ich
finde es nämlich auch so merkwürdig microsoft macht jetzt ja so ein so ein
riesenakt auf powerfulls beste stärkste konsole aller zeiten und sowas das mag
sein ja das kann man ja auch relativ objektiv belegen dass das dass die neue
xbox one die stärkste konsole ist das problem ist das bringt dir bloß nichts
wenn es dafür nichts gibt
nein hier geht es nicht hoch das bringt ja nichts wenn es nichts gibt dafür
wo sind sie moment da muss man dieses kack ding weg machen da kann man auch
letztlich
wo ist er wo ist er wo ist er gut dass du gut dass wir haben wir einen wir
haben wenigstens der uns carried so kommt das übelste flanke action übelste
flanke action achtung leute ich sag's euch flanke action des todes flanke
stellt jetzt ab xbox 360 battlefield war die beste zeit ja das stimmt generell
ich muss euch ich muss euch sagen die neue konsolen generation
hat mich hier hat sie vorm eingefleischten konsolenemen weiß ja
könnt ihr euch still noch dran erinnern hat mich dazu getrieben
das war sogar in aktuelle auslöser dass ich wieder mehr pc spiele schauen was
wir stehen hier nicht so optimal derzeit euch jungs ich weiß euch jetzt meinen
drei ft sphere gibt es noch viele aktive server deelli 4
himmels seals es geht es geht es geht aber das hat ein bisschen치를ие 8.600 100bs
dieselast und HD landscapes redaktion nach dem kauf Ts Reason wäre auf retz desto mehr wieder gear tempt.de
es geht
es geht also es ist auf jeden Fall spielbar
wenn ihr das Spiel nicht habt, lohnt sich das
Moment ich wollte Squad Cover, wollte ich ja wechseln zu nicht Ammo zu
was machen wir dann?
Sprint, Sprint ist immer gut
das ist so ungewohnt, wenn man die ganze Zeit Overwatch gespielt hat
das ist total ungewohnt
aber gucken wir mal, dass hier nichts kommt
Dauerfeuer Abenteuer geht
wir klitschen jetzt einfach da durch
guck mal
das war nix
da steht ein LRV auf der Brücke, das sollte mal vorpushen, sonst
bringt ihm das ja auch nix
oh da kommt was, da kommt was
oh und ein LRV
und der hat mich gesehen, der Typ hier vorne
die wollen rechts rumflecken, die holen wir jetzt
weggesprayt
oh jetzt wirds aber voll hier
jetzt wirds aber voll
easy clap, easy win
hast du schon mal die Beta von Monster Hunter
gespielt, du meinst dieses neue Monster Hunter MMO
also dieses, dieses Monster Hunter World
Hab ich noch nicht gespielt
Also, egal ob du das meinst oder nicht habe ich noch nicht gespielt
ähm
S Proper gibt's wie gesagt in Battlefield 3 noch einige
die neuen Xbox-Spiele sind auch mit Windows 10 spielbar
Da bin ich mal gespannt drauf
Da bin ich wirklich mal gespannt drauf, was Microsoft da macht
ähm
Was ich witzig fand damals
äh wie hieß das
öhm
Quantum Break, als das rausgekommen ist, was übelst kacke lief über Windows Store und alles.
Und danach gab es ja noch einen Steam-Release und jetzt ist alles gut.
Machst du mal wieder so einen Wunschzettel für Battlefield 18?
Hast du ja damals zu Battlefield 4 gemacht.
Ja, werde ich wahrscheinlich machen, wenn ein bisschen mehr über das Game bekannt ist.
Was ich mir wünschen würde ist, dass es nicht im ersten Weltkrieg,
nicht im zweiten Weltkrieg und nicht großartig in der Zukunft oder sowas spielt.
Ich würde mir für Battlefield 2018 wünschen, dass es entweder, was ich richtig geil fänden würde,
wenn es ein Bad Company 3 wäre.
Allerdings kein, wir schreiben nur Bad Company 3 drauf und wir machen,
sondern wir machen ein richtiges Bad Company 3.
Also sowas, wo man sich nicht hinlegen kann und sowas in der Richtung.
Was habe ich eigentlich für einen Ping?
Sieben. Schlechter Ping.
So, bouncen wir mal die Granate drüber.
Wir bräuchten eigentlich ein bisschen Smoke.
Da kannst du nicht raus, das ist das Problem.
Pre-Fire auf die Ecke.
Aber wir können die von vorne nerven, das ist okay.
Wir können die von vorne nerven.
Easy Cap.
So, nur gucken, dass keiner rankommt.
Falls ich irgendwas vergesse zu beantworten, weil Battlefield Rush plus Fragen beantworten ist...
Was? Was war das denn?
Bad Luck?
B-B-B-Was?
Was war jetzt daran bitte Bad Luck?
Ich bin auf die Kiste geklettert.
Also Kiste klettern ist schon...
Das überlastet anscheinend die Physik.
Battlefield Physik ist überfordert, wenn der Max auf die...
Der Max hat so dicke Arme, wenn der auf die Kiste klettert, dann ist Schluss.
Das kann...
Das kann es nicht mehr handeln, die Ingame-Physik.
Ja, falls ich irgendwie was vergesse zu beantworten, dann sagt mir Bescheid.
Und, äh, sag Max, warum hast du das nicht gesagt hier?
Erzähl nochmal.
Äh, machst du noch Overwatch-Videos?
Zum Beispiel Gameplay-Reviews?
Ja, also Overwatch, ich hab mir einen neuen Overwatch-Account gemacht.
Und hab den jetzt bis Level 25 gespielt und ein paar Routen rankt.
Allerdings fuckt mich das Game jetzt schon wieder total ab.
Deswegen glaub ich erstmal, dass ich da nicht so viel machen werde.
Ich werd was zur Overwatch-League sagen.
Overwatch-League war geil.
Bis auf ein paar Sachen, die mich genervt haben.
Zum Beispiel die Caster-Auswahl fand ich nicht so toll.
Wo kommt der her?
Oh, ich bin da richtig gut dabei.
2-0 unten.
Ich kann mich aufs Game konzentrieren und was dazu sagen.
Hallo, ich will da rein.
Nein, eh, eh.
The fuck?
Falsche Richtung.
Ich hab das Gefühl, die Leute sind ein wenig im Tri-Hand-Modus hier.
Hast du noch die Telekom 16K und Unity Media plus 100K?
Nee, hab ich nicht mehr.
Ich hab jetzt VDSL 100.
Also quasi 150 down und 140.
3 durch 0.
Mach mal ne Granate um die Ecke.
Ach, ich hab keine Granaten mehr.
Erwischt.
So, wir warten jetzt mal hier.
Vielleicht, ich wusste doch, dass...
Och, nee.
Der AD-Spam ist real.
What?
What the fuck?
Was war das denn?
Das kann doch nicht nur einer gewesen sein.
3-0.
Unberechenbare KD.
Versuch das mal auszurechnen, 3 durch 0.
Das ist wie der Ultraskiller.
Den konntest du auch nicht ausrechnen.
Halt.
Boah.
geht überhaupt nicht vorwärts
aber wenigstens kriege ich die ganze Zeit Rätsel
da nicht kann ich Chat gucken und
mich carry lassen
ich hab keine keine Munition macht
Fakt wird man dem Gamer Pass aufgehoben
was über dem Geld wird man dem Gamer aufgehoben
ich weiß nicht mehr
ich leise mich von dir abfahren
vergiss es
aber so ein bisschen Munition hätte was ehrlich gesagt
weiter geht's
wir haben einen Flankerino
wie der ist nicht gestorben
ich hab keine Munition mehr
ich brauch Munition
dein Lieblings-Berlin
ich find das geil wenn man nix machen muss und einfach gewinnt
übrigens dieses Win-Loss unten muss ich weg machen das ist noch ein Überbleibsel von
von Overwatch
ach eher gedrückt halten wir Kids aufheben
ja ich erinnere mich wieder
oh Halbkorn 450 ping
ne 450 ping kann man wirklich nicht spielen
ich hab Schiss
ich muss weg
Alter
Da kommt doch jetzt gleich was hier links.
War doch irgendwas.
Hab ich doch gesehen.
Wir müssen mal den Leuten bei A helfen.
Wir können hier schön in der Ecke campen.
Uh!
Komm, kriech.
Kriech vorwärts.
Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo der Typ genau ist.
Wow.
Bist du eigentlich IT-Administrator oder eher IT-Supporter?
Weder, weder noch.
Also ich war mal Admin.
Also immer noch.
Ist eigentlich immer noch so in die Richtung.
Aber war ich mal.
Mittlerweile
ähm
bewegt sich das, was wir machen, eher so
schon ein bisschen in
ich nenn's mal so ein bisschen Richtung Architektur.
Ja.
Und ich kümmere mich hauptsächlich um unsere Software-Repos.
Also sprich, ähm
ich hab das, ich hab das, ich hab letztens
einen Stream gemacht über Git.
Also sprich Versionsverwaltung mit Git.
Und da kümmere ich mich hauptsächlich
darum, also sprich, dass
ähm
neue Features rechtzeitig reinkommen
und, ähm, dass Sachen gefixt werden,
äh, dass es Beta-Builds gibt
und so. Solche Dinger halt.
Ist, ist ein bisschen, bisschen
schwierig zu erklären.
Magst du die viele FPS? Achso, siehst du's?
Ach, das siehst du gar nicht. 144 hab ich.
Und ich wollte einen V-Sync ausstellen.
Magst du, hast du schon Dark Souls
probiert?
Äh
Nee.
Ich hab, ich überleg grad, wie's heißt.
Das auf der PS4 hab ich probiert.
Das, was auch von den Dark Souls-Typen ist.
Wie hieß das denn?
Das, was so ein bisschen
auf Nordisch gemacht war, ähm
äh, ich hab's, äh,
wie hieß das denn? Leute, wie hieß denn
das Game? Ihr wisst das wahrscheinlich
gleich. Das war mal V-Sync off.
Easy 200 FPS. Machen wir hier Draw.
Ich mach mal FPS an. Draw.
Nee, wie war das? Render?
Render.
Draw. FPS 1.
Aber nee, haben wir.
200. Easy.
Bloodborne. Bloodborne hab ich mal angespielt.
Ja, aber nicht lang. Das fand ich ganz gut.
Das fand ich wirklich
nice. Aber
ich hab da nicht so
das, das
Durchhaltevermögen für das
Game.
Oh, die werden jetzt gebasht.
Die werden gebasht, die werden gebasht, die werden gebasht.
Ich dachte, die sind hier.
Wo sind sie? Wo sind sie?
Die müssen hier sein.
Irgendwo ist doch keiner gestorben eben, oder?
Gehen wir mal rüber.
Ich hör ein Heli. Wo ist der Heli?
Okay, Sound zu orten.
Woah!
Wir müssen gucken, dass sie uns nicht hier überrennen.
Guck, da sind sie nämlich schon auf dem Berg am Start.
Erstmal, erstmal heilen.
Heilen, heilen, heilen.
Mal gucken, wenn sie runterkommen. Wenn sie runterkommen, werden sie gebasht.
Paneele drüber schmeißen.
Dauerfeuerabenteuer.
Ich muss mich erst wieder an die Schussweise
vom Battlefield ein bisschen gewöhnen.
Wo sind sie?
Wo sind sie, die Jungs?
Scheint gerade ein bisschen einseitig zu sein.
Also, sobald
die Defender hier schon rauspushen können,
ist das meistens ein bisschen einseitig.
Da müssen wir vielleicht ein bisschen umsortieren.
Der Server ist
für den Arsch. Ja.
Warum?
Only 200 FPS.
Naja, ich glaub, mehr geht nicht.
Ich glaub, mehr geht in Battlefield 3 nicht.
Weil ich hab V-Sync aus und es gibt nicht mehr.
Also, diese Runde ist einfach.
Ich kann ja einfach stehen bleiben. Easy.
Easy, die Leute machen das schon.
Überhaupt kein Ding.
Läuft dein Teil
mit 5 Gigahertz?
Ja, mein Teil läuft mit 5 Gigahertz.
Sofern du mit Teil natürlich
meinen Prozessor meinst.
5 Gigahertz.
Der Sibaro, der sitzt da am MG.
Gibt ein Konsolenbefehl für die Max-FPS.
Ja, welcher?
Irgendwas gelegt.
Das gibt's doch nicht.
Schnell. Defuse. Easy-Defuse.
Da vorne ist noch irgendwo einer.
Gehen wir mal vor, gucken.
Also, die Runde ist ein bisschen einseitig.
Patrick, gibt's
einen Balancer?
Haben wir einen Balancer installiert, der
Squads beibehält?
Nach Möglichkeit.
Bestes Battlefield, ja.
Ja, also, hat vorhin jemand gefragt.
Also, mein Lieblings-Battlefield ist...
Also, eigentlich teilt sich der erste Platz
Bad Company 2 und Battlefield 3.
Battlefield 3 fast noch ein Ticken
lieber, weil ich
das einfach mag, dass das ein bisschen schneller ist.
Also, sowohl vom Movement her, als auch vom
Schießen her und allem.
Und Bad Company 2, weil es einfach Bad Company 2
war und einfach geil.
Und ich würde mir wünschen,
dass sie für...
Kann man hier rüber?
Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass sie für Battlefield
ein Spiel machen, wie gesagt, nicht im ersten oder im zweiten
Weltkrieg, sondern...
Oh, wie viele da sind!
Moment, sind die alle tot?
Ich check's grad nicht.
Nicht im ersten und zweiten Weltkrieg,
sondern mal wieder ein Game, was entweder, sagen wir mal,
so 1980 rumspielt,
bis 2000 rum.
Nicht in der Zukunft und auch jetzt nicht so super modern,
sondern mal wirklich irgendwas
so in dieser Zeit.
So ungefähr in dieser Zeit, wo Modern Warfare
gespielt hat. Das fand ich eigentlich
ganz gut. Da gab's nicht gar so viel
abgedrehtes Zeug, da gab's keine...
Nicht so sehr Drohnen zum Rumfliegen
und sowas in der Richtung.
Es gibt die ganzen Waffen,
die man so kennt, aus Spielen
und Filmen und allem.
Und außerdem hast du da potentiell die ganze
Welt als Setting.
In der Zeit.
Es muss ja kein...
Es muss ja nicht auf irgendwelche realen Sachen
basieren. Du kannst dir einfach irgendwas ausdenken.
Meinetwegen, ey,
in Battlefield 3 waren die Russen die Bösen, ja?
Sollen sie sich halt wieder auch...
Sollen sie sich meinetwegen wieder
die Russen die Bösen machen? Dann können sie das ja
wirklich mehr oder weniger auf der ganzen Welt spielen lassen.
Was würdest du mir wünschen für Battlefield 2018?
Aber ich hab ja das...
Das doofe
Gefühl, da kommt irgendwas
merkwürdiges jetzt so.
So entweder...
Battlefield
oder sowas,
wobei ich da wiederum nicht glaube,
dass das wirklich kommen wird,
nachdem die Leute so viel...
so viel rumgehatet haben
auf Zukunftsgames in letzter Zeit.
Das ist
nicht sonderlich fair gebalanced gerade.
Ähm...
Ich würd mir, wie gesagt,
Favorites Battlefield wäre...
Also wenn ich's mir aussuchen
dürfte, dann würd ich sagen
Jungs, macht Bad Company 3.
Allerdings...
Bad Company 3 halt wirklich Bad Company 3.
Also kein Battlefield
1, BC3,
sondern halt wirklich Bad Company 3.
Also was, wo man...
Wo man nicht liegen kann und da, wo das halt alles...
Ähm...
Man kann nicht sagen, dass Bad Company 2
comicmäßig war.
So in der Inszenierung vielleicht, aber...
Die Models und so hatten
in Bad Company ja einen komplett anderen Style.
Battlefield 3 und 4 und so, das ist halt voll auf
realistisch gemacht. Bad Company
hat immer noch so... War zwar realistisch
gemacht, aber hat immer noch so einen...
So einen Hauch, ähm...
Nicht Comic.
Wie könnte man das beschreiben?
So einen Hauch, so ein bisschen Inszenierung
drüber gehabt, dass du halt gesehen hast
in Bad Company, das ist halt Bad Company
und eben kein Battlefield 3.
Weiß ich, wie ich das beschreiben soll.
Äh, Domei Battlefield 3
PC, ja.
Nur PC.
Irgendwie haben sie ja alles durch an Szenarien.
Naja...
Also Kalter Krieg, könnte man viel machen.
Aber ich bin mittlerweile
so auf dem Standpunkt, wo ich sage,
hey,
man kann sich ja ein Szenario nehmen
aus der echten Welt
und
denkt sich einfach irgendwie was da drum herum aus.
Da hüpft er.
Der drifft mich doch eh nicht.
Achtung, Achtung, Achtung.
Komm, oh, der wird gebasht, der wird gebasht.
Der hält nicht mehr viel aus.
Oh ne, jetzt hat er auch...
Jetzt hat er einen Reparierungstyp mit drin, ey.
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich glaube Battlefield 3
war so beliebt.
Erstens, weil es natürlich genau zu der richtigen Zeit
rausgekommen ist. Das darf man natürlich auch nicht unterschätzen.
Das kam genau zu der richtigen Zeit raus.
Und weil es ein geiles Game war.
Moment, wo ist der Typ?
Wat?
Ja, danach müssen wir mal ein bisschen rebalancen
nach der Runde.
Wir ficken ja komplett
über die Gegner drüber.
Geht ja gar nix.
Also für die Gegner.
Ja, sondern weil Battlefield 3 eben auch ein richtig
geiles Game war, was nicht so den Mega-Hype hatte,
sondern das tatsächlich auch
dass der ganzen Sache auch gerecht
wurde. Was...
Ich finde Battlefield 3 hatte die beste Kombination
aus so...
Das sind ja die hässlichsten
Sandsäcke, die ich je gesehen hab, ey.
Ähm...
Es war immer noch relativ Arcade-lastiges
Gameplay,
aber genug Tiefe,
dass man nicht nach 2-3 Tagen
alles gesehen hat. Na, das kann.
Battlefield 3 war da so
die perfekte Mischung aus Leuten,
also für Leute, die es richtig wissen wollten.
Jetzt zeig ich euch mal Schleichweg hier.
Trick 17.
Äh...
Und Leute, die einfach nur spielen wollten.
Und durch...
Ja...
Und ich muss auch ehrlich sagen,
ich fand diese ganze Medic-Train, Red-Train
Geschichte auch nicht schlecht
in Battlefield 3. Das war zwar vielleicht
einen Ticken übertrieben, aber es hat wenigstens
dazu geführt, dass es eine ordentliche Anzahl
Medics gab und du eigentlich immer wieder
belebt wurdest, wenn du Teammitglieder hattest,
die ein bisschen mit Hirn gespielt haben.
Und es hat einfach um Längen mehr Spaß gemacht
und hat um Längen mehr Teamwork gefördert,
als alle anderen Red-Systeme,
die ich da so danach in Battlefield gesehen hab.
Ja, Toastinator
ist nicht sonderlich Balanced. Ich weiß,
wir müssen nach der Runde mal rebalancen.
Da kann man ja
während der Runde schlecht machen. So, hier.
Jetzt, jetzt hier.
Trick 17.
War zwar...
War überhaupt nicht notwendig, ne?
Wir rennen die, glaube ich, auch so.
Wir rennen die übertrieben.
Der Typ lebt noch.
Er will doch bestimmt seinen Teammate retten.
Es ist nicht sonderlich
Balanced, ja.
Müssen wir mal ein bisschen rebalancen danach.
Patrick, schau mal,
dass du Auto-Balance so machst,
dass das Squads, also sprich,
dass hier unser Squad, dass das zusammenbleibt.
Beziehungsweise, dass
Squads generell versucht werden zusammenzuhalten.
Weil ich hab das letzte Mal
schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, als ich Battlefield 3
gestreamt hab. Da gab's halt ganz lustige
Leute, die quasi nicht die...
nicht das Spiel gespielt haben, sondern einfach, wir rennen den Max
hinterher und versuchen überall zu killen und gucken im
Stream und sowas. Deswegen brauch ich
ein paar gute Spieler dabei.
Ja, Patrick, nicht nur ich vom Auto-Balance,
also auch die Leute, die ich hier gerade im...
im Squad drinne hab.
Und sowas fehlt
mir. Wenn man sich anguckt,
Battlefield 1 Rush, komplett für'n Arsch.
Battlefield 4 Rush,
sagen wir mal, halb für'n Arsch.
So Momente hier, das merkt man sich einfach. Wenn du an
Battlefield 3 Rush zurückdenkst, da fallen dir
genau solche Sachen ein. Da denkst du an
den Climber, man peakt hier runter, der Sprung runter
von diesem...
Was ist das eigentlich?
Was ist das eigentlich? Warum springt
man überhaupt vom Berg? Hab ich mich
noch nie gefragt.
Zumindest genau an das denkst du, wenn du an Rush
denkst in Battlefield 3.
Du denkst einfach an richtig geile Sachen, was du so
in Battlefield 4 nicht hattest. Aber mit
Battlefield 4 Rush verbinde ich zum Beispiel diese
Map mit der Satellitenschüssel, weil sie so kacke war.
Und das ist eigentlich auch nicht
die beste Variante, oder?
WTF? Da liegt er.
Das ist aber auch nicht das Beste, oder? Wenn das erste,
woran du bei nem Game denkst, ist, wie schlecht
ne gewisse Map gewesen ist.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, der EX
crasht. Ja, die Balance
ist trash, Leute. Ich weiß, das sieht man ja
gerade, aber wir können es ja schlecht...
Also ich finde, es gibt nichts Nervigeres als
Auto-Balancer, die dich während der Runde switchen.
Du hattest ne gute Runde und dann
kriegst du auf den Sack, weil...
Das ist nicht sonderlich balanced, das seh ich auch.
Ich mein, ich muss nix machen. Ich könnt mich jetzt hier hinlegen,
aber ich will die Runde trotzdem easy gewinnen.
Ich mach auch nix, sieht man ja.
Drei, zwei, alter...
Aber guck mal, ich renn einfach nur geradeaus,
guck ein bisschen Chat, ich muss überhaupt nix machen.
Das ist der totale Witz.
Gehen wir mal hier reingucken.
Nix da.
Oh, hier ist viel los.
Hier ist viel los.
Renn, renn, renn.
Der wusste genau, dass ich da durchkomm. Da hat mich irgendjemand gespottet.
Metro 64?
Nein, nein, das werden wir ganz bestimmt nicht spielen.
Es gibt in keinem
Battlefield was Schlimmeres als Metro
64.
Weg hier, weg hier.
Weg hier.
Oh, jetzt haben sie uns aber geschreckt.
Ja, jetzt haben sie uns geschreckt.
Zweimal gebasht.
Ja, nochmal Medipack hin. Guck mal, das
meine ich. Ich find das gut, dass es so viele Medics
gibt in Battlefield 3. Du hast immer einen da, der
dich wiederbelebt.
Was jetzt?
Hä? Ist der Server abgeschmiert?
Ich war's net?
Ich war's nicht.
Ich hab nix gemacht.
Best Nate ever.
Ah, fuck.
Ist doch keiner bei A drüben, oder? Kann das sein?
Moment, warum hab ich
KD 6-3? Hä?
Das hat die Map geswitcht, aber die KDs...
Was?
Haben wir den Server geklitscht, oder was?
Was ist denn das hier für...
Haben wir...
Haben wir das... Guck mal!
Die Stats wurden nicht resettet.
Keine Ahnung. Stopp, der Server ist kaputt.
Ah, fuck.
Ich krieg das Ding noch entschärft. War nix.
Okay.
Muss man nicht verstehen.
Was ist eigentlich deine Meinung zum Bitcoin-Hype?
Hm.
Also ich muss sagen,
das haben jetzt schon einige Leute gesagt, ob ich
mal ein Video machen kann zum Thema Kryptowährung
und sowas. Ich kann da ehrlich gesagt
gar nichts...
So viel zu sagen.
Also ich hab keine Kryptowährung.
Und...
Ich kenn mich da
ehrlich gesagt auch nicht sonderlich gut aus.
Ich brauch...
Ahahaha, shit.
Reds!
Blitz!
Ähm...
Aber diese ganze Geschichte mit...
Was gibt da noch mehr? Gibt da nicht nur Bitcoins?
Oh nee, oder?
Fuck, jetzt... Warum hab ich da draufgesprayt?
Ist der down? Ah, der ist down.
Ist einfach so.
Es ist halt...
Oh fuck, der Panzer.
Du siehst mich nicht, Panzer, ne?
Du siehst mich nicht.
Siehst du mich? Du kannst mich gar nicht sehen.
Ihr seht mich nicht, Panzer.
Easy clap.
Panzer sieht mich nicht.
Oh fuck, der Panzer sieht mich doch.
Also mit Stat-Reset wär schon ein schlecht...
Ah, ich will wieder...
Ne, da kommt's nicht weg. Vergiss es.
Ähm...
Ja, was wollt ich denn sagen? Diese ganze Kryptowährung-Geschichte...
Also sei es jetzt...
Natürlich, Bitcoins kennt der mittlerweile echt...
Es gibt eigentlich kaum noch einer, der keine Bitcoins kennt.
Oder es gibt ja noch mehr hier.
Ethereum und...
Monero und...
Was es da alles gibt.
War Monero nicht, was Cristiano Ronaldo auf seiner Homepage hat meinen lassen?
War das nicht Monero?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr.
Es ist halt so ein bisschen Spekulation.
Es gibt...
Tausende Kryptowährungen.
Tausende Kryptowährungen, wo natürlich
schön die Ersteller pre-mined haben,
ganz am Anfang.
Und das heißt, wenn man da jetzt
investiert, und man investiert ja nicht nur,
indem man sich jetzt eine Kryptowährung kauft,
sondern halt, indem man da auch Stromkosten reinsteckt,
also Stromverbrauch und alles,
Hardwarekosten reinsteckt, um das Ganze zu minen...
Ich muss hier weg.
Was mach ich hier eigentlich?
Du setzt halt drauf, dass
die Kryptowährung, für die du dich entscheidest, oder auch
wo du drauf spekulierst, dass die
sich gut entwickelt. Erstens, dass diese
Kryptowährung sich überhaupt
durchsetzt. Was mach ich denn da?
Ich kann nicht labern und spielen gescheit.
Dass diese Kryptowährung sich überhaupt durchsetzt.
Oh!
Ähm...
Dass die im Kurs nicht fällt und
am besten, mindestens gleich bleibt.
Am besten steigt.
So, und...
Wir machen jetzt, Achtung, Achtung,
Flankerino des Todes machen wir jetzt.
Super Flank.
Super, der Super Flanker.
Ist da.
Der Super Flanker.
Oh, fuck, Granate.
Aber es müssen hier doch noch mehr Leute an der Ecke sein.
Jawoll, jawoll, jawoll.
Recht, ohuh! Wie viel da drin liegt.
Wie viel da drin liegt.
Drei Milliarden. Eigentlich wollte ich jetzt außen drum rum
flanken.
Wie schützt man sich am besten vor versteckten Minern auf
Websites?
Eigentlich gar nicht.
Eigentlich gar nicht. Du kannst
mit sowas wie NoScript und so, kannst du natürlich
Javascript blocken.
Oh, ich hab ne Donation, ich guck gleich nach.
Ähm, kannst du natürlich sowas wie Javascript blocken.
Aber es gibt
sehr viele Webseiten, die
da muss man einfach
Javascript aktiviert haben.
Versucht mal Youtube ohne Javascript zu verwenden.
Ja, oder irgendwie die, deine Bank
Webseite.
Oder, es gibt ganz viele Sachen.
Twitter, wobei ich glaub Twitter geht ganz gut ohne
Javascript. Aber zumindest nicht schön.
Versucht mal irgendwas ohne Javascript zu verwenden.
Das hast, das hast schon mal gelitten.
So, was man machen kann ist,
man kann Drittanbieter Javascript blocken.
Also sprich alles was nicht,
also alles was nachgeladen wird.
Allerdings, wenn es natürlich
die Website, alter was ist denn hier los.
Wenn es natürlich die Webseite ausliefert,
auf die ihr gehen wollt und die Javascript
braucht um zu funktionieren, dann
könnt ihr euch da im Endeffekt nicht
großartig vorschützen. Ich weiß nicht
ob es da mittlerweile irgendwelche Browser Plugins
gibt, die analysieren, was aus
geführt wird, was wieviel CPU Last verursacht
und sowas in der Richtung.
Ähm, keine Ahnung.
Ich, das kannst du ja voll vergessen
hier irgendwohin zu pushen. Das ist ja einfach nur
out in your face gibt es ja gerade nur.
Warum
sagt mein Surfer eigentlich die ganze Zeit
Example Message 212? Ähm,
Rex Inferos,
danke für die Donation.
10,58, äh nein 10,51 Euro.
Finde es gut, dass du immer noch
Videos machst. Schaue dich schon seit Jahren.
Wie geht es deiner Katze? Ähm, die Katze
die lebt nicht mehr. Die Katze ist im
April gestorben, die war krank.
Die ist aber 14 geworden.
War ja schon ziemlich alte Katze.
Warte mal, hier ist die Baro, gibt es Heal.
Haha, genau über
mir, ey.
Kriegst du einen Ratz?
Ich muss mich jetzt ein bisschen mal
auf das Game konzentrieren. Geht gerade überhaupt nicht.
Bin mir nicht zu, wenn ich die ganze Zeit Chat
gucke. Spawn Camping, wir
stehen noch bei uns. Schleichen
wir uns an, schleichen wir uns an.
Dann sind schon alle weg. Okay, wir campen wohl noch.
Ein bisschen spawnen, wie es scheint.
Uuuuh.
Was für ein Virenprogramm dazu. Ähm, ich habe
auf meinem neu installierten Rechner
also ich hatte die ganze Zeit ja immer das
von Avira.
Zur nächsten Runde werden
die Stats wieder geresettet.
Ne, Neborasius, hier wird nicht
outstrafed. Kann ich auch.
Fuck.
Haha.
Ähm, immer das von Avira.
Allerdings
mittlerweile habe ich nur noch
das von Microsoft.
Also sprich, das Windows Defender
was dabei ist.
Das was schadenmäßig dabei ist.
Das reicht auch.
Neue Runde, neues Glück. Jetzt auch mit
reseteten Stats.
Patrick, weißt du warum?
Das war, weil wir eben die Map geswitcht haben. Einfach mal so random.
Ich habe ein paar Sachen
übersehen.
Also falls ich irgendwas, ich blicke jetzt im Chat
gerade nicht mehr durch. Falls ich irgendwas übersehen habe,
schreibt es einfach nochmal.
Deswegen den Instant Spam, ne?
Oh, jetzt wird attackt.
Jetzt wird attackt.
Lull 3D, größer Lull. Ja, das ist das.
Richtig.
Lull ist eindeutig größer Lull.
Sehe ich genauso.
Muss ich gerade hinlegen.
Äh, nur Vanilla Maps. Ja, ja.
Es gibt genug Leute, die haben kein Premium.
Und das letzte Mal hatten wir sogar mit Leuten, die Premium hatten Probleme.
Achtung, Achtung. Wir schnellsten uns hier jetzt ran.
Wir schnellsten uns hier jetzt ran.
Und dann werden sie geschreckt.
Oh, der hat Glück gehabt.
Uh.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass man das kaputt machen kann.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Granate.
Das ist Overwatch Reflex gewesen gerade.
Das Gewackle.
Hä?
Mein Kopf war weg.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt mal,
dass hier kein Nachschub lang kommt.
Daneben sehe ich nämlich schon wieder irgendeinen Typ rumstehen.
Wisst ihr?
Jetzt ist er weg.
So, wenn wir die hier schon weghalten.
Au!
Dann haben wir die hier irgendwann auch aus...
Das finde ich halt
so geil an Battlefield.
Battlefield 3, es gibt kein Game, wo so
so die Fetzen fliegen, ey.
Suppression.
Suppression. Halten wir mal drauf.
So.
Medipack, Medipack.
So, jetzt ne Granate drin. Das ist gut.
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein.
Ach, fuck.
Ich muss sagen,
ähm,
das geht. Also ich finde,
dass in Battlefield 3
die Schüsse
klar, manchmal ist es vor allem
durch, ähm, durch dieses komische
Suppression Zeug ziemlich kacke.
Also, dass du
komplett woanders hinschießt, wo du hinzielst.
Aber an sich habe ich das Gefühl, wenn du
hier triffst, kommen die Schüsse meistens auch an.
Was ist denn?
Ey, ich meine, man muss sagen, das ist
bloß ein 16-16-Server. Das ist kein
64-Mann-Metro-Server.
Also,
Metro ist es nicht, sieht man offensichtlich.
Der Red Strain ist
real.
Fuck, Alter.
Rätst mich nur einer?
Ne, gibt keinen Rätst mehr.
B ist auch
so assi.
Moment.
Spawnrape? Was ist hier los?
Sehe ich das richtig? Spawnrape?
Ne, ne, Leute.
Wir lassen uns nicht spawnrapen.
Wobei es schwierig ist, hier rauszukommen.
Jebaited.
Was?
Also, eine ordentliche Balance
zu finden ist wirklich so schwer in dem Game.
Das geht, das geht vom
vom totalen Spawnrape bis zum
Gegnerspawnrape.
Das ist echt hardcore.
Wollen wir das hier wegsprengen?
So, ich bleibe jetzt einfach hier genau
durch diese Ecke.
Ah, Spray, Spray, Spray.
Bashen, Bashen. Die werden jetzt wieder gerätst.
Aber wir lassen die nicht rätsten, ne?
Im Scope in die Fresse.
Da geht ja mal gar nichts.
Das ist so schwierig,
diese
die Balance hier zu finden.
Wir suppressen jetzt einfach mal.
Oh, ne.
Jetzt waren wir fast durch.
Aber das finde ich geil an Battlefield 3.
Nicht dieses Spawnrape,
dieses Spawnrape-Geschiss, ne?
Sondern, dass es einfach,
ich kenne kein Game, wo so krasse Action ist.
Granaten übers Dach.
Ja, das stimmt, wir hätten uns mit einem
Supporter,
mit ein paar Supportern davor setzen können
und uns rüberwerfen
und sowas.
Gab es in Battlefield 3 auch schon
Semi-Auto-Shotguns mit Frag-Munition?
Nicht, dass ich mich erinnern könnte.
Falls es das gab, hat es zumindest nicht so genervt.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen Follows.
Und wer zuguckt und noch nicht gefollowt hat,
ist natürlich gerne eingeladen,
den Follow-Button zu drücken auf Twitch.
Dann seht ihr auch, wenn ich online bin.
Nein, wieder Caspian Border.
Nein, Kack-Map.
Die Map muss weg.
Ich hasse die Map.
Warum haben wir überhaupt eine Rotation drin?
Ich muss jetzt gerade noch mal gucken,
wo man hier ist.
Map-List, Map-Rotation.
Ich glaube, hier kann man das umstellen.
Was? Will ich den Kack spielen?
Was ordentliches Spielen.
SandCrossing. Habe ich auch gerade schon gespielt.
Habe ich auch gerade schon gespielt.
Spielen wir nochmal. Geile Map.
Kann man immer spielen.
Echt, es gab Spreng-Munition.
Ich kann mich da null dran erinnern.
An Battlefield 3.
Zumindest hat es nicht so genervt.
Ne Patrick, wir können die nochmal spielen.
Loser Candles Rush.
Loser Candles Rush ist total underplayed.
Nachdem ja alle Loser Candles Dings spielen hier.
Loser Candles TDM.
Mal gucken, ob jetzt auch wieder...
Scheiß auf das andere M kommt.
Das ist eh nicht richtig zu halten.
Ich habe hier so die Ultra-Plays gemacht auf der Xbox.
An diesem Spot.
Ich brauche Munition.
Was war denn das jetzt schon wieder?
Was hat denn hier die Leute gefragt?
Hä?
Kann es sein, dass es die Trümmer sind, die vom Dach runterfallen?
Diese Action, das haben sie nur in Battlefield 3 hingekriegt.
Und das funktioniert auch nur, weil du retzen kannst.
Das funktioniert nur, weil du retzen kannst.
Stell dir mal vor, du könntest nicht ordentlich retzen in diesem Game.
Wie solltest du sowas denn hier jemals spielen, Gescheit?
Geht gar nicht.
Kannst du komplett vergessen.
Das geht nur, weil du hier Magic Train spielen kannst.
Danke für die Donation, ich guck gleich nach.
Ich seh das nämlich bei mir nicht richtig.
Das heißt, wenn ihr wollt, dass ich kurz nicht spielen kann, müsst ihr mir donaten.
Nein, nein, jetzt hört doch mal auf.
Ich weiß da eh immer nicht, was ich sagen soll, wenn Leute Sachen donaten.
DerSibaro hat donatet.
So ein BF3-Stream tut echt gut.
Hab mich schon richtig drauf gefreut.
Ja, ist nice, wenn es dir gefällt.
Ich hab den Stream da.
Guck mal mal die andere Seite, was hier so los ist.
Nix.
Hahaha, Halbkorn, Sabine31 Sniper.
Haha, Halbkorn, Sabine31 Sniper.
Ja, dass sich daran noch jemand erinnert.
Ich hätte mich da selbst dann mal...
Halbkorn, war das nicht Simone31?
War das nicht Simone31?
Der Sniper, der auf Dämmerwein peakte,
die ganze Runde Attacker im Gras gelegen hat und gecampt?
Der Sniper, der auf Dämmerwein peakte, die ganze Runde Attacker im Gras gelegen hat und gecampt?
Doch, doch, das war nicht Sabine, das war Simone31.
Doch, doch, das war nicht Simone31.
Ach, äh, stimmt.
Wollte ich noch was dazu sagen.
Haben gesagt, sie wollen ein Remake von Battlefield 3.
Ich hab das Gefühl, in letzter Zeit kommt immer wieder so nach dem Motto,
Hör die neuen Teile, sacken, lass Remake machen.
Ich seh das ein bisschen anders.
Sie sollen ein neues Battlefield machen,
was so gut ist wie Battlefield 3.
Wir brauchen kein Battlefield 3 Remake.
Wir brauchen...
Wir brauchen ein gutes Battlefield, wie Battlefield 3.
Also quasi im Geiste von Battlefield 3.
Wir brauchen kein Battlefield 3 Remake.
Wozu? Wozu sollste das Remaken?
Die können sich das doch angucken.
Die haben 30.000 Analysten
und sonstige Dinger, die sollen sich einfach angucken.
Fuck, was?
Ach stimmt, da kommen ja die Gegner raus.
Sollen ein bisschen Feedback sammeln, sich das angucken,
ein paar Prototypen basteln, ein bisschen testen
und da kommst du relativ schnell drauf.
Was du machen musst,
wenn du ein Spiel basteln willst, wie Battlefield 3.
Und dazu kommt,
was ich auch nicht verstehe, ist, dass DICE sagt,
ja, sie können kein neues Bad Company machen,
weil sie haben ja angeblich verlernt
und sie wissen nicht mehr,
was... Ich hab den Gegner übrigens rechts gesehen.
Äh, sie...
Fuck!
Sie wissen nicht mehr, was Bad Company ausgemacht hat.
Dann frag ich mich,
wollen die uns echt verarschen?
Ich mein,
das sind die Entwickler von diesem Ding.
Natürlich wissen die,
was das Game ausgemacht hat.
Wenn nicht, sollen sie sich mal ein paar Dokumente
und Design-Geschichten von damals raussuchen.
Oder sie sollen ein paar Fans
von Bad Company fragen, die können ihnen das sofort sagen,
was das Game ausgemacht hat.
Ich kann ohne Probleme in 20 Minuten
ein Video dazu machen, was
für mich Bad Company 3 ausgemacht hat.
Das ist, finde ich, einfach eine billige Ausrede.
Oh, fuck.
Um nichts zu sagen, eine richtig billige Ausrede,
ähm,
ist ja einfach zu sagen,
hey, wir wissen überhaupt nicht mehr, wie das geht.
Ja, ihr habt den Scheiß erfunden.
Ihr wollt
einfach nicht. Und ihr wollt es
den Battlefield-Fans nicht sagen, dass ihr nicht wollt.
Deswegen sagt ihr
einfach jetzt, wir wissen es nicht mehr.
Das ist so, wie wenn einen an der Schule
gefragt wird und er sagt, oh, ich hab's vergessen.
So ungefähr
ist die Antwort von DICE zum Thema Bad Company.
Wir brauchen
Battlefield 3 ohne Suppression.
Es gibt, es gab ja mal diesen
diesen Mod,
diesen Battlefield 3 Mod.
Uh, voll in die Fresse, Alter.
Alter, was geht's denn mit dem Typ alles?
Ich muss hier weg.
Easy, easy,
easy clap, easy win.
Es gab ja mal diesen, diesen Venice,
Venice Unleashed, oder wie das hieß.
Das hat ja ein paar Sachen
versucht, so diesen Blau-Filter zu entfernen
und sonst was, aber das ist nie abgehoben.
Ob das überhaupt noch in der Entwicklung ist.
Ich habe lange nichts davon gehört.
Ich glaube, das ist dead.
Ich meine, man konnte in
Battlefield 3 ja Suppression auch zu seinem Vorteil
nutzen. Du konntest,
du konntest beispielsweise kurz aus der Deckung rausgehen,
in die Richtung vom Gegner schießen, dann wusstest du
schon mal, er kann dich jetzt nicht mehr so
ohne weiteres treffen.
Bugsfire? Nee, Battlefield 3
hat seinen Anfang an Suppression gehabt.
Das kann ich mich nämlich noch
dran erinnern. Das war eines der ersten Videos, wo ich mich
darüber aufgeregt habe.
Wie random und kacke Suppression
ist.
Schon wieder Bazaar?
The fuck?
Warum schon wieder Bazaar?
Hä?
Mach, äh, ähm.
Ich bin immer noch zu doof, das
einzustellen. Patrick, können wir
nicht mal Dings spielen?
Zum Beispiel, zum Beispiel
Losher Cannon's Rush, oder so.
Moment, die Map Rotation hat auch noch
plus drei, nur noch vier Maps drinne.
Da ist
irgendwas nicht so ganz richtig.
Terran Highway.
Komm Jungs, wir spielen mal Terran Highway.
Wir spielen, wir spielen.
Terran Highway spielen wir jetzt.
Beste.
Finde ich, eines der besten Rushmars.
Habe ich immer gern gespielt.
Was geht mit dem Server ab?
Dann spielen wir
danach Terran Highway.
Patrick, ich glaube, wir sollten nicht beide an dem
an dem Server rumdoktern.
Ich überlasse das dir.
Alle Maps, die ich geflamed habe,
ich habe bisher jede Map geflamed.
Warte mal, ich mache mal eine Map Rotation,
die mir gefällt, warte mal.
Grand Bazaar, Sandcrossing, Demoman Peak, Losher Cannon's
Terran Highway ist gut.
Ähm.
Cark Island ist noch ganz gut.
Firestorm mag ich nicht.
Caspian Border mag ich nicht.
Ja, so lassen
wir das jetzt. Au.
Den hat es zerrissen, den Heli.
Den hat es zerrissen.
Wo kommt hier was?
Gehen wir mal links lang gucken.
Da unten war doch was. Ich habe doch da was
gesehen gerade. Ne, ne, ne.
So nicht, Kollege. So nicht.
Wo kommen sie denn jetzt her?
Da unten. Irgendwo ist ja unten einer am Steg
oder so.
Nein. Oh. Jetzt wollte ich gerade weg.
Flieg Heli. Nein.
Nein. Ich flieg kein Heli.
Wenn ich Heli fliege, ist
Instant Crash. Ah.
Fuck. Wisst ihr was auch noch geil in
Battlefield 3 war? Fällt mir gerade so ein.
Das die Kugeln durch die Gegner durchgeflogen sind.
Du konntest in Battlefield 3
richtig gut, wenn du gut gestanden hast und
die Gegner von der Seite erwischt hast, konntest du
5, 6 Gegner wegklatschen.
Wenn du es
mit ein bisschen Glück und wenn du es richtig gemacht hast.
Das wäre in anderen
Battlefields nicht möglich gewesen.
Haha, Kollege.
So nicht. So nicht.
Jetzt bin ich so langsam, aber
sicher wieder ein bisschen drin im Game.
Bist du noch in Overwatch aktiv?
Der letzte Stream hier vor diesem Stream war Overwatch.
Ja.
Aber ich habe so richtig Overwatch
habe ich seit Season 3 nicht mehr gespielt.
Ich habe mir jetzt einen neuen Account gemacht.
Ich habe mir jetzt einen neuen Account gemacht
bis Level 25 und habe die Placements gespielt.
Placements liefen natürlich über
zu erwarten relativ gut.
Wenn du erst mal gegen Platin und so
gematcht wirst, dann kannst du
die Placements nicht mehr spielen.
Wenn du erst mal gegen Platin und so
gematcht wirst, dann
ging das schon.
Wo sind sie?
Da ist einer in der Ecke.
Was?
Was war das denn jetzt?
Ach, das war Rättsimmunität,
hä?
Jetzt kam ich mich gerade verarscht vor.
Fuck.
Das war Rättsimmunität. Ich habe mir schon gedacht,
was ist hier los? Erst mal das ganze Magazin in den Kopf geschossen?
Nö, habe ich überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Das ist mir jetzt nichts.
Da habe ich jetzt keine Lust drauf.
Jetzt zu sterben?
Nö, das ist kein Bock. 15 Schuss in den Kopf?
Ach nee, das ist...
Das macht nichts.
Passiert nichts. Kein Ding.
Komm, jetzt jagen wir das Zeug in die Luft ab.
Was ist denn hier los schon wieder?
Wir müssen uns
mal ein bisschen verpissen.
Versuchen wir nochmal rumzuflenken.
Ah, erwischt.
Wo sind eigentlich unsere Leute hier?
Ne, der andere ist schon weg.
Das war Respawn-Schutz, ja.
Ja, stimmt schon.
Was hältst du von Moira in Overwatch?
Ich frage mich, warum die noch einen
Non-Aiming-Held reingebracht haben, fragt
der Shinyboy97. Ja, das frage ich mich zum Teil
auch. Also ich finde,
Overwatch braucht nicht mehr Auto-Aim.
Definitiv nicht.
Overwatch braucht mehr
Helden wie Genji, Tracer,
Ana und
sowas in der Richtung, wo du
Huge Plays machen kannst. Allerdings
halt auch für was können musst.
Ähm, Moira verstehe ich
an sich auch eh
allgemein nicht so richtig. Ich meine, das ist ein
Close-Range-Healer mit recht ordentlichem
Damage.
Wer Overwatch League geguckt hat,
hat vielleicht das letzte Game von Dallas Fuel
gesehen, wo sie Moira versucht haben auf
Junkertown zu spielen.
Also E-Ax bei mir geht's.
Ich habe überhaupt keine Lags.
Und das hat
ihr überhaupt nicht hingehauen.
Also WWPDD,
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass man
echt nicht aus Bronze rauskommen kann.
Ich meine,
wenn man ganz gut ist,
ownst du ja auf Bronze quasi
in jedem Fight vier Leute.
Paar Tickets mehr würden dann schaden. Ja, ich habe
das Gefühl, es ist
entweder kriegen wir auf
die Fresse oder die Gegner auf die Fresse. So 100%ig
balanced ist das nie.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass es am Sauber liegt.
Bei mir laggt nichts.
Das eine, wo ich eben gedacht habe,
es laggt, war Respawn-Schutz.
Spielst du ein bisschen League?
Was für League?
Was meinst du?
Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
ich war richtig dumm. Warum bin ich hier lang?
Ich will hier hoch. Da hoch
will ich. Oh, oh, oh, oh, da steht
das Auto und schießt mir direkt
in die Fresse.
Mach mal mit Anderson Hill ein Dual
über das neue COD.
Ich habe das neue COD ein bisschen gespielt auf dem PC.
Man kann das nicht mehr spielen, weil das schon
voll mit Cheatern ist.
Wenn ich da jetzt zu einem Video mache, flame ich das Game
und kommt nichts Sinnvolles
bei raus.
Ich verstehe eh nicht,
warum sich den Kram jemand für den PC kauft.
Das ist jedes Jahr das Gleiche.
Ich meine, ich habe es mir auch gekauft, ja.
Es ist halt witzlos, wenn man sich das mal überlegt.
Es ist voll witzlos. Du bringst ein neues
Game raus und weißt eigentlich schon, du kannst es nur die
ersten 1-2 Wochen richtig spielen, weil es
danach verhackt, vercheatet,
versonstet wie Sau ist und
es interessiert den Hersteller nicht.
Das ist halt
ganz schön für den Arsch.
So, jetzt warten wir mal, was hier kommt.
Woah!
Langustel.
Treffe ich hier
eigentlich nichts? Was ist das?
Okay, wir treffen alle nichts. Ist auch gut.
Kann ich mit leben.
Ich schau mal ab. Okay, jetzt in das Auto
zu rennen wäre taktisch nicht so geschickt.
Fuck! Ah, scheiße.
Moment, da hat man Fuß rausgeguckt, ne?
Nice.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Mann, die schmeißen aber auch mit Granaten
hier rum.
Bester Kill aller Zeiten.
Reicht die Granaten soweit?
Meines League of Legends...
Ne, LOL. Auf LOL habe ich überhaupt
keinen Bock. Reizt mich überhaupt
nicht. LOL ist so ein Game, es geht
komplett an mir vorbei.
Diese ganze MOBA-Geschichte ist nicht meins.
Ich finde Overwatch ist
einfach
das beste Game der letzten Jahre.
Problem ist bloß, Rank ist
so mega verkackt,
dass man es
nicht länger als zwei, drei Tage spielen kann,
ohne übelst rum zu ragen.
Hallo, Minzmann.
Okay, vorwärts.
Flankerino.
Next.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, fuck.
Ich wusste, dass von links einer kommt.
Ich wusste es. Ich wusste bloß nicht, von wann.
Äh, äh, wann, von wo, so rum.
Hahaha.
FiveEddy, was hältst du davon, dass
Rainbow-D-Panther-New gefällt hat?
Interessiert das im Jahr 2017 wirklich noch jemand?
Gibt es den überhaupt noch?
Was sagst du zu Hearthstone?
Wow, ist da jetzt
kein Schuss angekommen mit TF?
Ähm, Hearthstone ist ein sehr
spaßiges Game.
Allerdings viel zu
random.
Man kann jetzt sagen, ja, das ist quasi so
eine, allein schon dadurch, dass du halt
Karten random ziehst,
ist es random, aber ich meine,
ich habe früher mal Yo-Gi-Oh! gespielt.
Ganz gut. Und, ähm,
das war
nicht so random.
Wie ist eigentlich der Zombie-Modus im neuen COD?
Habe ich auch nicht gespielt. Ich wollte,
ich wollte schon vor einer ganzen Weile Zombie spielen.
Zombie-Modus spielen.
Ich habe schon wieder vergessen.
Ich habe mal auf Twitter gefragt,
wer hat Bock auf Zombie-Modus?
Und da haben sich ein paar Leute gemeldet, die auch
keine Ahnung, 200
Runde irgendwas
World Record hast du nicht gesehen spielen.
Und
mit denen wollte ich eigentlich mal spielen zusammen.
Gibt es doch nicht, ey.
Ähm, ich habe irgendwie, ich habe
bestimmt Donation gekriegt.
Oh, oh, oh, ich muss wieder ingame.
Der
Chris95, äh,
hat 5,40 Euro donatet. Dankeschön.
Er schreibt, hallo Max, wollte
hiermit einfach mal Danke sagen für die jahrelange
tolle Unterhaltung. Leider kommt ja nicht mehr so viel
von dir mit anderen
YouTubern wie damals mit dem Friseur und Kaboom.
Trotzdem schön immer noch was von dir zu hören.
Da kann ich dir zu sagen, ich habe
geplant, also ich will jetzt ja im Dezember wieder
mehr Videos machen. Ich habe mit einigen Leuten was geplant.
Ähm,
ich habe jetzt leider nicht die Liste da, wo ich
alle aufgeschrieben habe. Aber, ähm,
es ist was mit älteren Bekannten, mit
neuen Leuten, mit denen ich schon nie was gemacht habe.
Mit ein paar Leuten, die
Overwatch-Content machen.
Mit ein paar Leuten, die, ähm,
Hardware
Content, wie nennt man das so?
Hardware-Content, keine Ahnung, so
Hardware-Reviews und sowas machen.
Ähm, da sind
ein paar Sachen geplant. Also ich werde
diesen Monat relativ viel mit anderen Leuten machen.
So, next.
Willst du mich verarschen hier?
Guck mal, wie, wie er da mit seinem Kack-Sniper
steht und rumsprayt.
Oh, Heal. Heal-Pleats.
Was meinst du,
wie Battlefield 5 wird? Tja, das ist noch
nicht so wirklich abzusehen.
Das ist noch nicht so wirklich abzusehen.
Tja, flanken
wir mal ne Runde.
Hast du noch kein Kontakt zu Kaboom? Ab und zu mal?
Boom!
Ab und zu mal gehen wir noch was essen.
Schlimm ist, ich hab nix. Ich kann dagegen
nichts machen. Oh, fuck.
Das ist ausgerechnet, wenn du einen Typen daneben
rumstellst.
Ja, Bad Company 3 wäre nice, das stimmt.
Bad Company 3 wäre das
Beste, was wir machen können.
Ein ordentliches Bad Company 3.
Nicht so ne Kacke.
Wie gesagt, nicht einfach nur Bad Company 3
draufschreiben, sondern auch
Fuck! Sollen wir auch Bad Company 3
machen.
WWPD, es ist Lul3D, nicht
LOL3D. Wir sind ja immer noch auf Twitch.
Auf Twitch wird generell nicht gelo-
gelollt, sondern nur gelullt.
Wo ist eigentlich meine Waffe hin?
Das ist nicht meine Waffe, aber
die ist mir lieber. Kann ich jetzt
auch was gegen dieses komische Luftabwehr-Ding
da unten machen?
Hui! Guck mal, ob wir was treffen.
Ich glaub's. Oh, was? Wir haben getroffen!
WTF. Das hab ich jetzt
nicht für möglich gehalten, dass wir das treffen da unten.
Hopp, hopp,
hopp, hopp.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ich kann mich mal selbst heilen.
Scheiße. Wo ist denn, wo ist denn hier
ein... Ist irgendwo ein... Ah, hier ist
ein Midi-Pack. Perfekt.
Flankerino von der Seite.
Wat?
Äh, kannst du einstellen, dass
mehr Spieler draufdrehen? Also das ist jetzt schon
absolut chaotisch und man blickt gar nicht mehr
durch. Und es ist schon 60
gegen 16. Rush, ohhhh.
Rush kann man einfach nicht gescheit
spielen mit 32 gegen 32,
deswegen
kann ich da leider nichts dran ändern gerade.
Ist ein bisschen problematisch,
hier gerade gegen dieses Luftabwehr-Ding.
Hopp.
Und weg. Hopp.
Wo sind Gegner?
Da sind Gegner.
Da sind Gegner. Und die wissen
auch, dass ich da bin. Das ist nicht gut.
Oh, da oben ist er.
Ja, jetzt wurden wir überrannt, hätte ich schneller
moven müssen.
Dann eben 16 versus 32.
Ganz bestimmt.
Hallo, spring rüber.
Du kommst hier dann raus?
Haben wir es jetzt eigentlich gelegt? Ja, ich glaube,
schon, oder? Ich glaube, wir haben es gelegt.
Ja, ah, ist weg.
Suppression 0.
Achtung.
Jetzt rennen wir einfach los.
Oh, oh, oh, wir rennen nicht los.
Perfekt.
Super.
Ich dachte, wir können jetzt schon mal vor.
Nostalgie pur
mit Battlefield 3.
Das ist nicht der erste Battlefield 3 Stream,
den ich gemacht habe. Ich habe schon ein paar gemacht.
Der jagt uns ein bisschen hin und her,
hier.
Scheiße, du kommst hier nicht raus.
Kannst du voll knicken.
Die Rushrunde ist sogar ganz ausgeglichen.
Oh, jetzt kommen hier die
Pro Flanking Strats.
Gut, dass ich ein Delay drin habe.
Hat auch nichts gebracht.
Das Delay hat
auch nichts gebracht.
Alter.
Das kannst du ja mal so knicken.
Erwischt, erwischt, erwischt.
Oh, Mörser.
Ich habe ganz vergessen,
wie anstrengend Battlefield 3 ist.
Man findet in Battlefield 3
überhaupt keine Spieler mehr, abgesehen von
deinem Server. Das stimmt nicht.
Ich habe die letzten Battlefield Streams
gespielt, ohne dass ich einen eigenen
Server hatte.
Das war überhaupt kein Ding.
Das war überhaupt kein Ding, mit Spielern zu
finden, das letzte Mal.
Fuck, fuck, fuck. Ich habe Schiss.
Was? Wer hat mich denn jetzt gekillt?
Ach, von da hinten kam noch einer.
Oh, lass mich spawnen, lass mich spawnen.
Was?
Du kommst ja kaum vorwärts.
Aber wir haben es gleich.
Wir haben es gleich.
Das ist echt anstrengend.
Limbo Chains, Mörser,
das sind zwei R zu viel.
Oh, Mann. Der war schlecht.
Der war schlecht.
Oh, 2013, beste Stats.
Ach so. Sorry.
Diese Win-Loss-Anzeige wollte ich ja wegmachen.
Die ist noch von Overwatch
übrig geblieben.
Das ist doof, dass man
im Ladebildschirm
keinen Chat aufmachen kann
in Battlefield 3.
Sonst muss man da natürlich das obligatorische
GG Eats reinschreiben.
Oh, beste Map.
Sehr nice.
Johann
Enzle.
Das kann
ich mir gut vorstellen.
Aber das Game hat ja glücklicherweise
einen Modus für Farbenblende.
Taugt das was?
Taugt dieser Modus überhaupt was,
wenn man so Probleme hat?
Was ist denn hier schon wieder los?
Hallo, ich will da rein.
Darf ich nicht.
Ich möchte mal anmerken, dass ich übertrieben Hunger habe.
Hier kommst du ja.
Bitte hilf.
Suche Gegner.
Und keine Panzer.
Der stirbt nicht.
Wollte ich gerade sagen, jetzt aber, oder?
Und jetzt wird das Haus gestürmt.
Hast du schon mal Competitive Battlefield
angeschaut? PS4?
Ne, ich habe mir mal
so einen Trailer
angeschaut, den sie
immer gezeigt haben für dieses Incursion.
Weil ich
nicht glaube, dass das
abheben wird.
Ehrlich gesagt.
Was denkt ihr zu Battlefield
Incursion?
Battlefield 1
Inkursion.
WTF.
Ja gut, man sollte mit dem Panzer nicht stehen bleiben.
Was will man hier stehen bleiben?
Ah, da.
Krasser Schneiper.
0-3-D ist das beste Kommando.
Das macht man jetzt ja
normalerweise nicht hier, ne?
Oh, oh, oh.
Ist der abgesprungen?
Nein, Moment.
Wo ist mein Teammate?
Hier war doch eben noch ein Teammate nebendran.
Wie wäre es dann mit Rush Carg Island?
Stop, das kommt danach.
Achtung, Achtung, jetzt kommt
Flank Mode.
Max Flank Horse.
Battlefield, ich will da hoch.
Ich höre den Gegner direkt
vor mir, aber ich komme nicht hin.
Ah.
Boah.
Seiße.
Jetzt werde ich hinter
den Gegner geflankt nach 3 Stunden
und dann überfährt mich so ein Kack-M-Truck.
Ich will es reuen nicht, ey.
Wir müssen übrigens
defenden.
Wird sonst nichts.
Allerdings, so wird das auch nichts.
Über mir.
Gab es hier eigentlich irgendeine Möglichkeit
hochzukommen, ohne dass man es...
Nein, das schafft man nicht.
Kann man es schaffen durch das Aus hier zu rennen?
Keine Chance.
Es geht ab mit den Typen.
Hast du ein bisschen Schiss hier raus zu gehen,
ehrlich gesagt?
Der Typ ist immer noch da.
Gucken wir mal hier.
360 Nate.
Oh, nein. Die Granate war nichts.
Hätte aber
klappen können.
Fliegen die Fetzen.
Boah. Alter, ey.
Das ist wirklich
nicht ohne hier gerade. Du kannst nirgendwo rausgucken.
Da, unter
mich. Äh.
Sonics 3.
Das...
Gibt es das nicht? Das gibt es kaum.
Kostenlos.
Was gibt es kostenlos?
Fuck. Du kannst
nicht mal deinen Kopf hier irgendwo rausstrecken,
ohne dass du instant gefickt wirst.
Das ist schlimm.
Ja, du hast...
Was willst du hier machen?
Auf Origin gab es das kostenlos.
Also, wir werden
ganz schön geownt.
Ganz schön geownt.
Gehen wir mal durch die Kisten hinten lang.
Kistenstellen ist das Beste.
Bisschen hin und her gewackele.
...
Kommt man hier eigentlich irgendwo durch?
Ne.
Kommt man nicht.
Auch nicht da hinten, ne? Ne, ne.
Kistenstells. Und dieses
Jumpshot-Dingsprung,
sonst was für Döns, ist auch so ein bisschen
Angewohnheit, die man eigentlich
im Battlefield 3 gar nicht gebraucht hat.
Da kommt jetzt was durch gleich.
Nope.
Die Knight.
Erwischt. So ein bisschen auf den Panzer
aufpassen. Oh, oh.
Panzer, Panzer.
Oh, oh.
Den hat's aber zerrissen.
Ach, fuck. Einmal nicht
hingeguckt in die Richtung.
Und schon gefickt.
Der Panzertyp ownt uns übrigens.
Ich glaube, ich muss
noch auf Engineer zurückschwenken.
Oh, Diffuse, Diffuse, Diffuse, Diffuse.
Nice, MVP. Wie auch immer
Diffuse dran. MVP.
Eindeutig.
Hey Max, wie kannst du denn
in Battlefield 3 spielen?
Warum nicht?
Versteh ich nicht.
Warum soll ich das nicht spielen können?
Ich hoffe, der Sibaro hat den Gound da oben.
Jetzt fickeln wir mal
von der Seite rein. Nein, machen wir nicht.
Wir werden gebasht.
Schlimm. Kann der mal sterben
jetzt? Zum Glück liegt hier ne...
Oh, ich wusste
nicht, in welche Richtung er kommt.
Hey Max, spielst du noch Hots...
Mach ihn platt.
Oh, nee.
Da wurde er gerackt
vom Skipper-SMG.
Wir halten das ganz gut.
Muss aufpassen
beim Vorlaufen, weil...
Ja, ist klar.
Die ganze M16-Tryhard-Waffengeschichte
da.
Hast du übrigens
228 Führer. Ja, ist sogar
noch...
Ist sogar ein bisschen
gesunken, aber...
Das waren vorher noch mehr.
Was übrigens auch der Grund ist,
warum ich keinen Sub-Button hab.
Es ist mir auf Twitch alles nicht so...
Nicht so wichtig,
da ich jetzt hier Ultra-Tryhard-Twitch-Mode
machen will. Ich will einfach alles mögliche
zeigen, streamen, sonst was,
wo ich Bock drauf hab.
Und sonst nix.
Ich hab auf der Xbox immer
M16-Tryhard gespielt.
Oh, nee.
Haben sie jetzt gelegt?
Ja, sie haben gelegt.
Scheiße, da kommen wir nicht ran.
Der Panzer davor, der Amtrak.
Panzer davor, Amtrak daneben.
Komm, wir probieren's.
Aber ich glaub nicht, dass wir das hinkriegen.
Wir können höchstens
Tickets
vorher.
Aber nein.
Aim. NA.
NA-Aim.
Das war das.
Max, wie sieht's mit Overwatch aus?
Wie soll's mit Overwatch aussehen?
Ich hab letzten Stream nur Overwatch gespielt.
Allerdings ging mir das Game schon wieder
hardcore auf den Sack.
Das Matchmaking von Overwatch ist einfach
so pale
und macht so überhaupt keinen Spaß.
Auf allen
Leveln.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Blizzard
denkt, sie wissen es besser.
So nach dem Motto,
das, was wir als Spieler erzählen, ist Blödsinn.
Oder ob sie
das nicht irgendwie
eingestehen wollen
oder so, dass es nicht richtig funktioniert.
Oder zu stolz sind,
abzugucken, wie machen's andere.
Keine Ahnung, ich kann das bei Blizzard
schlecht
vorstellen.
Oh, hat da schon
einer gelegt?
Fuck, da hat schon einer gelegt.
Jetzt müssen wir aber zurück.
Sag mal, das ist die erste
halbwegs ausgeglichene Runde, kann das sein?
Wo in der weder wir komplett
gespawnrapt werden, noch die Gegner.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh, jetzt sind sie
ein bisschen voll hier.
Achtung.
Blup.
Next. Jetzt ist ein bisschen viel los hier.
Jetzt müssen wir uns mal verpissen.
Ich versuch sie nochmal wieder zu beleben, die Jungs hier.
Kann das sein, dass neben mir drei spiegeln
Gegner sind gerade?
Weg, weg, weg, weg, weg, weg.
Och man, das mit diesen
Mini-Packs, das ist
in Battlefield 1 immer noch so, oder?
Dass du Leute nicht richtig wiederbeleben kannst,
die Mini-Packs auf sich liegen haben.
Oder geht das mittlerweile?
Ok, man darf hier nicht durch, verstehe ich.
Weil Battlefield
Logik.
Ach ja, ich hab hier vergessen,
Spawnschutz.
Muss man irgendwelche Kriterien
erfüllen, damit man
Subs auf Twitch haben kann?
Oder musst du eine Verpflichtung mindestens
eine Woche... Ja, also es gibt
solche
Lichtlinien, so nach dem Motto, so und so viele Tage
die Woche streamen und sowas.
Also für Affiliate kriegt ja
quasi jeder ein Angebot, der schon
ein bisschen streamt.
Ich habe aber so überhaupt keine Ambition,
ehrlich gesagt,
so einen Twitch-Partner zu machen, bis jetzt.
Mal gucken, ich meine, wenn
jetzt von Twitch einer sagen würde, hier
lasst mal drüber
reden oder so, würde ich nicht sagen, nee, kann
ich auch nicht.
Aber ich werde mich da jetzt
nicht irgendwie drum bemühen, erstmal.
Weil das Schöne ist,
so kann ich wirklich komplett streamen, wenn
ich Bock habe.
Und auch das zeigen, worauf
ich Bock habe, ja, also.
Theoretisch könnte ich
sogar auf Twitch und YouTube gleichzeitig streamen.
Was du als Twitch-Partner
natürlich nicht darfst.
Findet man noch viele Server? Es geht eigentlich.
Es geht.
Also Battlefield 3
findest du noch Server.
Kannst Rush immer noch spielen, ist kein Ding.
Also Rush,
es gibt Demavent Peak Only.
Server gibt es ein paar.
Oh nee, ich dachte, wir können
da drunter durchfahren.
Müssen wir uns mal kurz verpissen hier.
Ja, Fanatics, die Achievements
habe ich schon.
Düsen wir da mal rein.
Gucken, dass wir keine
Minen auslösen.
Ah, das ist mein Panzer.
Da drüben ist der Panzer.
Gerne noch die zeigen mit
Kanister, Shell und sowas,
wo die Leute One-Hit-Tasten über die ganze Map
mit dem Panzer.
Das war nice.
Volle Pulle, nein.
Wir fahren nicht ins Aus der Map.
Battlefield 3 ist heute noch mit Abstand das beste Battlefield,
finde ich auch.
Dicht gefolgt
allerdings, was heißt mit Abstand?
Dicht gefolgt finde ich von Bad Company 2.
Beides übertrieben geile Games.
Moment, warum sieht man
dieses Kack-Zeug, warum geht das nicht kaputt?
Rekt!
Triffst nix.
Panzer!
Moment, was, das hat nicht getroffen?
Jetzt aber.
Jetzt habe ich irgendwas von der Seite angehauen.
Berg.
Hinter mir, hinter mir
war einer.
Das ist 100 pro einer mit
Sprengstoff.
Hier sind die halt.
Da habe ich so ein bisschen Schiss, ehrlich gesagt.
Komm, scheiß drauf, wir düsen da jetzt rein.
Nein, da sind noch ein paar in der Base drin.
Bam!
Schreckt.
Der muss hier irgendwann raus, der Typ.
Oh, oh, wir brauchen Heal.
Ich bleibe jetzt einfach drinnen.
Scheiße.
Na gut, schneller, na gut,
mehr hätte ich erwarten können.
Moment, wir haben doch die Base.
Warum kriegen wir sie auf den Sack?
Oh, fuck.
Okay, wir müssen hier durch.
Gib Gas, Alter, gib Gas.
Hoho.
Das finde ich halt geil.
Du musst in Battlefield 3, musst du dir nicht so
künstliche, only in Battlefield
sonst was, bla,
irgendwie Momente ausdenken.
Du hast sie einfach.
Das ist doch das Beste.
Könnt ihr euch noch an diese Battlefield 4
Hallo?
Moment, da ist kein kleiner drinne.
An diese Battlefield 4 Werbekampagne,
wo sie die ganze Zeit erzählt haben,
boah, so krasse Kills,
ich bin Heli geflogen und da habe ich den Gegner platt gemacht.
Oh, aber das Tolle ist, Battlefield ist ein ultra
geiles Game.
Weißt du, es ist doch viel besser, wenn das Game natürlich sowas hat,
anstatt, dass du da irgendwelche
YouTube-Typen oder sonst
wen hinsetzt, der erzählt, wie geil das Game ist.
Was es dann gar nicht ist.
Fuck, Mann. Was ist denn hier los?
Moment, warum
ist der Typ nicht down?
Huhuhu.
Treppen, please.
Ach, hinter mir ist ein...
hinter mir.
Kommt der denn hinter mich?
Und wie...
Ich stehe direkt am Panzer dran.
Nein.
Da geht es halt übelst ab.
Bestes Game.
Achtung, Amtrak.
Ich mache jetzt mal YOLO, YOLO-Style.
Was geht mit dem da ab?
Kommst du um die Ecke gerannt,
ahnst nichts Böses, zack,
du kannst nicht im Gesicht stehen.
Achtung, YOLO.
Ey, renn, Alter, nicht stehen bleiben,
renn.
Da schneipert es.
Von rechts hat es geschneibert.
Nein, das war jetzt nicht so die beste Idee,
da eine Granate hochzuschmeißen.
Man's not hot.
Erwischt. Weg hier, weg hier, weg hier.
Achtung.
Jemand?
Nein.
Den hätte ich erwischen müssen.
Den hätte ich killen müssen, der defused jetzt noch.
Ohohoho.
Knapp, richtig knapp.
Patrick ist so schlimm mit Server installieren,
ja. Ich habe das ja auch mal gemacht.
Ich habe das eigentlich in Erinnerung, dass ich
das...
Das geht. Also ich fand's, fand's
nicht so schlimm.
Spray and pray.
Alles weggesprayt, da ist ja noch mehr.
Ne, jetzt war's das.
Jetzt sind sie aber alle down.
Ich hole den.
Äh, doch, oh, oh, oh.
Komm raus.
Hahaha.
Den hat's zerrissen, der Typ.
Äh, Falkorion.exe
Den Zusammenhang verstehe ich
nicht so ganz. Er schreibt, es wird
aber mit Sicherheit in nächster Zeit ein
Game wie Battlefield 3 oder Bad Company
rauskommen. Es ist gerade voll
im Trend, so OP-Kits wie in
Battlefield 1 einzubauen,
damit auch jeder No-Hand mal einen
Kill machen kann. Ja, das stimmt, aber warum sollte es dann
gerade ein Game geben wie Battlefield 3?
Was ja solche
No-Hand-Geschichten nur sehr begrenzt hat.
Es gab in Battlefield 3
auch so ein paar Sachen, ja.
Aber das ist ja nix gegen diese
SMG-Kits zum Aufheben
beispielsweise in Battlefield 1.
Wer bei DICE kam eigentlich
auf die glorreiche Idee zu sagen, hey,
ähm, ETF,
äh, bei DICE
zu sagen, hey, Jungs, wir
bauen Kits ein in Battlefield,
wo man
25 Kills mitmachen kann,
wo man mehr aushält, mehr Damage macht,
schneller schießt und
das ist alles überhaupt kein Problem. Das ist
doch bestimmt ne gute Idee, oder?
Und dann muss irgendjemand bei DICE gesagt haben, ja, das ist
eine super Idee, lass uns das doch machen.
Ist auch nicht schwer,
was da im Kopf kaputt war
bei denen.
Fuck. Ach, du meinst kein
Spiel wie Battlefield 3 rauskommen soll in
nächster Zeit? Ja, das denk ich.
Ich befürchte es fast.
Ich hoffe es ja nicht, aber ich befürchte
es fast.
Aber,
man muss sagen,
dieses ganze, mit jeder kann man
nen Kill machen,
ja, man sieht, dass
halt auch Games schon erfolgreich haben können,
die ein bisschen, die ein bisschen Tiefe
an sich haben.
Ich find, das ist auch so ne Sache,
woran Overwatch,
an denen Overwatch vielleicht scheitert,
dass sie,
dass sie sich nicht richtig entscheiden
können, ob casual oder eben
competitive.
Das ist echt ein Problem für Overwatch,
find ich.
Und ich mein, man muss sagen,
klar, du konntest in Battlefield 3 schon übelst die Leute zerreißen,
ich mein, hier, guckt euch mal Hexe an,
der Typ basht sie alle weg.
Und das, obwohl er noch nicht mal hier Assault-Spieler
mittendrin ist.
Du konntest in Battlefield 3 auch übelst bashen,
ja, aber es war immer noch,
es war noch eigentlich relativ einsteigerfreundlich,
bis zu nem gewissen Punkt.
Und das hat auch für Leute,
die sich damit beschäftigen wollten,
verboten.
Also ich hätt gerne Bad Company 3 auf dem PC.
Ein ordentliches Bad Company 3.
Ob sie jetzt die Story
im Singleplayer fortführen oder nicht,
ist mir ehrlich gesagt ziemlich egal.
Wobei ich die
Story vom ersten Teil schon ganz cool fand.
Also naja, gut, die Story vom ersten Bad Company
war bescheuert, ja, aber das war ja das Gute
da dran.
Und halt vor allem die,
die Leute aus der Kampagne.
Battlefield 3 war der Sniper noch geil.
Bad Company 2 war der Sniper,
war sowas von mega OP.
Das hat wahrscheinlich schon
fast jeder wieder vergessen.
Wie OP Sniper
in Bad Company 2 gewesen sind.
Auf der Konsole allerdings
hauptsächlich,
wie es auf dem PC ist,
weiß ich nicht, auf dem PC gab es dieses
Ranzoom-Auto-Aim in der Form nicht.
Also wer das nicht kennt,
auf der Xbox und der Playstation konnte man
in Bad Company 2, wenn jetzt, so hier, der,
ich kann nicht mal den Namen lesen,
der Mega-Lola, wenn das jetzt der Gegner ist,
dann bist du in Bad Company 2 ran gerannt,
mit dem Sniper, und hast es so gemacht,
und warst instant drauf auf ihm.
Weißt du, du hast ran gesoomt und so,
das hat Auto geaimt auf den so.
Allerdings nur auf der Konsole, auf dem PC
musste man glaube ich selbst zielen.
Latrias, du brauchst kein Browser-Plugin mehr.
Das geht so.
Du musst einfach nur Origin offen haben
und dann im Chrome beispielsweise auf Server-Join
hier klicken.
Was mache ich hier eigentlich?
Hubschrauber geiern.
Mit No-Skill-Lock-On-Waffen.
Lock-On-Waffen waren damals
die richtigen Noob-Dinger, worüber sich
alle aufgeregt haben in Battlefield 3.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Haben sich alle drüber aufgeregt und gesagt
Oh nein, Lock-On-Waffen,
warum gibt es sowas?
Aber wenn man sich mal überlegt,
wie schwierig hier beispielsweise sowas
umzusetzen gewesen wäre, wie in AT4.
Kann sich noch jemand an den AT4 erinnern
in Battlefield?
Äh, in Bad Company 2?
Oh, High-Skill-Gameplay.
Oh, der Typ will mich on.
Ich dachte zumindest, er will mich on.
Kann sich noch jemand dran erinnern an die AT4?
Sowas umzusetzen in Battlefield 3
wäre ganz schön schwer gewesen.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Aber AT4,
das war die einzig wahre
Luftabwehrwaffe.
Da musstest du dann so schießen und so
Okay, da ist der
Flugzeug-Battle am Start.
Geil, wenn man den Heli,
wenn er wieder angestellt kommt.
Oh, oh, an B, an B geht was.
Der denkt, ich komm von vorne,
aber ich komm nicht von vorne.
Ich dachte eigentlich,
der sitzt da drin und wartet.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Der brennt aber, der muss gleich raus.
Lol, Alter, du musst
jetzt gleich raus, dann wirst du gebasht.
Fuck.
Jetzt ist er raus.
Und jetzt wollte ich das Ding noch schnell
reparieren, aber das hat nicht funktioniert.
Übrigens, danke für die ganzen
Follows, ich guck gleich mal rein.
Ah, man sieht nicht mal viel, man sieht bloß die letzten
paar. Ah, Heligeiern,
Heligeiern, Heligeiern.
Du-du-du-du-du-du-du.
Die Flares sind raus.
Äh,
da hat's ihn zerrissen.
Nicht, dass du meinen Diffusor abschießt,
hier, was soll das?
Hast die Finger von meinem Diffusor-
Rekt.
Ja, stimmt, AT4 gab's in Battlefield 4,
da hat man gesehen, dass es nicht funktioniert.
Oh, oh.
Achtung.
Bad Company 2
war alles halt auch noch ein bisschen größer und langsamer.
Die war versackt.
Muss was anderes spielen.
Die Helis machen eh nicht so viel.
Das war auch das, was Bad Company
ausgezeichnet hat, dieses bisschen
behebigere
Movement und Gameplay.
Und dass es relativ
wenig nerviges Zeug gab.
Gab ja, ich mein, Bad Company
2, du hast, finde ich, genau die richtige
Waffenauswahl. Du hast,
jede Waffe hat sich unterschieden voneinander.
Du hattest
keine 35 Assault Rifles,
wie sich eins wie das andere spielt.
Nein, wozu?
Das ist total überflüssig, ja.
Warum stirbt hier alles
um mich drum rum?
Oh, fuck.
Ich wollte den ja jetzt einschätzen.
Der X.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
Oh.
Jetzt werden wir weggesniped.
Ganz vergesslich muss ich
viel mal respawnen.
Respawnen und
RPG rein.
In UAO ist er.
Fuck.
Wo kommt denn der Typ her?
Der stand ja direkt vor der Lase, direkt.
Soll ich jetzt sagen, so eine halbe Stunde
oder so machen wir noch bis 18 Uhr.
Dann ist mir das...
Scheiße.
Das ist echt anstrengend.
Habe ich gar nicht mehr so in Erinnerung.
Ich habe den Gegner übrigens gesehen.
Ich dachte, ich komme noch rechtzeitig weg.
Der X.
Ne, jetzt werden wir ja gerade total überfahren.
Zum Glück hat man
den Redstrain am Start. Da sieht man mal,
wie sehr das eigentlich Teamwork fördert.
Alter.
Hier geht ja nichts.
Und warum durfte man in Battlefield 4
eigentlich im Springen nicht mal schießen?
War das zu anspruchsvolles Movement
oder was?
So rum, weil man trifft eh kaum was.
Ich kann mich doch daran erinnern,
wie es mit dem Xbox-Controller war,
das hier drüber zu laufen. Da hast du per mal
eine Sprungtaste gehämmert.
So bist du da hier drüber gehüpft.
Weil es rumge... Weil es verbuggt war.
Wie sau, dieses Movement-System am Anfang.
Dieses Movement-System, was quasi erst
seit Battlefield 1 richtig funktioniert.
Richtig funktioniert.
Das ist das,
was sie in Battlefield 1 gut gemacht haben.
Dieses dynamische über die Map-Movement
zum ersten Mal richtig.
Seit Battlefield 3.
Links, es kommt einer.
Das war noch einer.
Erwischt. Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Der denkt, er kann mich owen.
Nein! Oh, du Drecksack!
Du... Oh, warum läufst du auch da oben lang?
Ah, fuck.
Outplayed!
Rekt.
Gebadet hat er mich.
Weiß.
Der ist direkt vor meiner Nase, der Typ.
Hallo, Battlefield.
Hier ist noch einer.
Jawoll.
Und da unten sind ganz viele.
Hier neben sind auch ganz viele.
Und da ist ein Panzer.
Warum ist hier so viel los?
Jetzt werden sie geownt.
Ich glaub, die wissen nicht,
dass ich hinter ihnen bin. Kann das sein?
Boah, ich hab nicht einen Schuss
auf den Typ getroffen.
WTF?
Äh, ist Delos dein Lieblings-Overwatch-League-Team?
Ja.
Also, ich war ja schon immer ein großer Envyus-Fan
und Envyus ist jetzt halt Delos Pew.
Zumal ich die Spiele auch einfach nice finde.
Sowohl von dem, wie sie drauf sind,
halt auch, wie geil sie spielen.
Die bringen auch immer was Neues, ja.
Weißt du, andere Teams spielen meist so den
klassischsten Shit ever, so Junkertown,
Bastion und sonst was. Und Delos probiert auch mal
was anderes.
Was für die Zuschauer natürlich auch toll ist,
wenn es nicht immer der exakt gleiche
Tempel ist.
Ich hab Schiss, dass der Panzer mich basht.
Sind ja ganz viele Panzer.
Die haben nicht mal viele Tickets,
das kriegen sie dann mal hin.
Den Panzer, den debaten wir uns jetzt.
Ah ne, der hat schon, schon weg.
Steigt der noch?
Jetzt steigt der auch noch in den Panzer ein.
Aber würde ich auch machen.
Warum auch nicht?
Hat ein bisschen gedauert, bis ich wieder
in das Game reingekommen bin.
Wo ist er?
Der ist da oben drauf, oder?
Tollisch!
Overrated, Cheatbaited,
Outdated.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, wie viele, wie viele, wie viele.
Erstmal, erstmal.
Oh, schön.
Oh, oh, renn!
Nice, schön gemessert.
Oh, die wollen, die wollen zu B flanken,
hä?
Wollen die zu B flanken, sehe ich das richtig?
Easy win.
Oh, Donation.
Donation, ich guck gleich nach.
50 Euro!
Eieieiei.
Killed by Sniper Limit.
Ja, Sniper Limit muss.
Sniper Limit muss sein.
Danke für die 50 Euro.
Du bist jetzt mit Abstand
sowas von Top Donator, Patrick.
Also schon, schon
Meilenweit
vorne, ja.
Ihr verdient, glaube ich, zu viel Geld in der Schweiz.
Ich glaube, ihr verdient in der Schweiz
zu viel Geld.
Aber trotzdem, danke für die 50 Euro.
So.
Eine Runde machen wir noch.
Danach muss man was essen.
Ich hab übelst Kohlenampf.
Wie lange bin ich denn eigentlich on hier?
Uptime.
Äh.
Oh, das war doch ganz ordentlich.
Rush ist immer noch der beste
Game Mode, ja, das stimmt.
Rush, beste.
Wow.
Was ist mit dem los?
Hat jemals schon irgendjemand
mit diesen MG Booten wirklich was gekillt?
Ich kann mich da nicht
dran erinnern. Oh, das ist
aber ein scheiß Landepunkt hier.
Am besten wäre außen
rechts oder so gewesen.
Ich hab, glaube ich, noch
nicht einen Kill mit diesen MG Booten
gemacht seit Battlefield 3 Spiele.
Oh, oh. Hier ist ganz schön was los.
Wo ist er?
Achtung, hier sind noch mehr.
Wir müssen aufpassen, dass wir nicht
gebetet werden.
Fuck, ich wurde gebetet.
Der Typ war irgendwo unter uns.
Achtung, Achtung.
Auf, beweg deinen Arsch rauf.
Noch mehr Donations.
Eieiei, was soll ich denn da machen hier?
Hört auf zu donaten. Ich weiß gar nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll.
Jetzt kommt das Ibaro noch.
56, oh Gott.
Leute, ihr verdient alle
zu viel Geld. Danke für die Kohle.
Wie gesagt, donatet
nicht so viel. Erstens weiß ich
dann immer nicht, was ich da drauf sagen soll.
Und außerdem
gibt es wahrscheinlich Leute, die haben es echt nötiger.
Aber trotzdem finde ich
das nice. Nicht falsch verstehen.
Alter,
verpiss dich, Alte.
Hätte ich mal ordentlich getroffen.
Rosenblödschen, gerade wieder OW gespielt.
Bei dem Scheiß wird man irre. Ja.
Das ist auch so mein Problem mit Overwatch.
Ich geh mit dem ab.
Was?
Ich soll mich fake freuen, dass ich
alle meine Fans liebe?
Das wisst ihr doch.
Das sind die besten Fans auf der Welt.
Ich kann das nicht.
Ich kann das echt nicht.
Ich krieg das nicht hin.
Also wer das echt besser
konnte, als kein anderer, war
HerrTutorial.
Keiner konnte besser
seinen Fans danken, wie HerrTutorial.
Was das angeht.
Keiner kriegt das so gut hin.
Gibt es den eigentlich noch?
Debated.
Gibt es den noch?
Ewig nichts mehr gesehen.
Ich meine, man muss sich das mal
anhören, die Soundkulisse von Battlefield 3
ist auch so geil.
Das laggen beim Überspringen von Objekten
allerdings nicht.
Montvix ist down.
Bester Name, Montvix.
Achtung, Achtung, der denkt jetzt.
Ach, Debated.
Ich hab gedacht, weißt du wisst ihr,
der wurde jetzt gehittet,
der will sich jetzt heilen,
der hat jetzt keinen Bock drauf,
jetzt kannst du vorhin nichts retzen.
Aber hier, OutMetaGamed.
Was, HerrTutorial gibt es noch?
Heißt aber nicht mehr so.
Wie heißt der denn jetzt?
Ist Tutorial Out, heißt der jetzt
HerrAnleitung, oder?
Wie heißt der jetzt?
Weißt du, mit 50 Kaliber Maschinengewehr
zweimal im Kopf, oh nö, ich bleib stehen.
Das ist überhaupt kein Ding. Easy.
Mit Realismus und Games hatten wir es ja schon mal.
Die sind alle immer weg,
bevor ich draufschießen kann.
Der heißt
Samisilma,
der hieß doch schon immer so.
Also, der hat sich jetzt quasi,
der hat seinen Channel so benannt, wie er L heißt.
Okay.
Die haben keinen Bock zu sterben.
Ich hab auch keinen Bock mehr Maschinengewehr rumzuballern.
Was, WAS?
Debated,
warum ist der nicht gestorben?
Das war Debated des Jahres gerade.
Aim overrated.
Max outdated.
Now off.
Kommen wir da nochmal irgendwann ran?
Also, mit Defense
haben es beide Teams nicht so.
Äh, sorry, mit Attack.
Hier war doch eben noch einer.
Ist er down?
Bam, b-b-bam, b-bam.
Jetzt wirst du geowned.
Rechts war noch was.
Nicht, wo er genau hin ist.
Leute,
was bedeutet Debated?
Ähm, das ist ein Emote und es heißt halt
Baited.
Ja, ähm, Baited, also wie könnte man das
gelockt, verlockt,
gelockt irgendwie,
wie könnte man das gescheit, ähm,
Na, wenn dich halt einer verarscht.
Man könnte es mit verarscht übersetzen, so.
Trifft es eigentlich ganz gut.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Das geht aber gerade
nichts vorwärts hier.
Mit mächtigen
Zähne zu 4.
Geködert, oh Patria, geködert
ist gut. Das, das trifft es genau.
Gebaited.
Geködert, das ist, das ist die beste
Übersetzung, die ich davon bisher gesehen habe.
Da ist doch auch einer drin,
oder? Habe ich, da habe ich mich verguckt.
Ich glaube, Max hat noch nie was anderes
als M416 gespielt.
Seit ich wieder Battlefield 3 spiele.
Ich finde es auch die beste Waffe aus,
ähm, die, die nicht
quasi M16 ist, weil M16 ist einfach
Kacke.
Also, das beste Waffe im Game.
Zu OP, ehrenlos
M16, deswegen spiele ich
M416.
Ist das Auto schon explodiert?
Hammer! Wir haben
keinen Bock zu sterben.
NA aim gepaart mit
zu wenig Damage.
Treffen wir den?
Zumindest suppressen
können wir.
Ja, das sollten wir haben. Das haben wir.
Ich glaube nicht, dass hier irgendeiner
uns von A noch basht.
Uh!
Dreck!
Bäh, bäh, was?
Was?
Was war denn das wieder?
Das war so ein
geiler Battlefield-Tod irgendwie.
Outdated, outdated, overrated.
So, der muss
sich jetzt mal verpissen.
Das ist ein Panzer, da machen wir nix.
Zumindest ich
keine Angst, dass
er MG hat.
Ich geh da jetzt raus.
Jetzt werden sie geownt.
Was auch richtig geil ist, hier mit dem Fallschirm
oben aufs Dach. Sobald man hier auf dem Dach ist,
hat man einen schon gewonnen.
Ach stimmt, man durfte ja nicht
in die Richtung reinspringen.
Boah!
Ich hab ihn nicht gesehen.
Fuh!
M16, M16.
Weißt du ja gleich.
Was ist los?
M416 nicht!
M416 wärste.
Ich renn da jetzt einfach mal rein.
Ich blick da mal durch.
Das ist mir zu hoch.
Ich...
Was? Ich blicke nicht mehr durch.
Das ist zu hoch.
Das heißt, wenn man Overwatch gewöhnt ist,
ist das zu viele Explosionen auf einmal.
Bei Overwatch ist das anders.
Bei Overwatch sind es nicht 3 Milliarden
Explosionen, die dich verwirren,
sondern 30.000 verschiedene Farben,
und verschiedene Blitze und Effekte von allen Seiten.
Effekt Overkill
ist wirklich so ein Problem in Overwatch.
Du blickst manchmal nicht mehr durch, was passiert.
Jetzt haben sie noch Moira eingebaut
mit ihrem komischen Strahl in der Ultimate,
dass du noch weniger durchblickst.
Da siehst du gar nichts mehr, wenn ihr den Strahl in die Fresse feuert.
Max, machst du mal
Community-Zocken auf deinem Server?
Ja, was mach ich denn gerade?
Was? Was meinst du, was das sonst ist?
Drei mal das zu raten.
Ratz, ratz, ratz, ratz, ratz.
Ich ratz euch noch schnell.
Ah, der wird schon gerätzt.
Ich hab Schiss.
Oh, fuck. Also,
irgendwie kommen wir hier nicht vorwärts.
Du bist eingeschneit, one gentleman.
Ja, ich hab
heute übrigens Gartenstelz 2-0
aufgenommen, wen das interessiert.
Ich hab auch das Grab von der Katze
mal gezeigt.
Boah, wie es mir auf den Sack geht gerade.
Geht ja gar nichts.
Gut, dass letzte Runde ist.
Ich bin ja hier richtig gefestet gerade.
Was?
ETF.
Ach.
Ist keiner vom Stream hier?
Keiner, aber wenige vom Stream, okay.
Ja gut, da kann ich jetzt auch nichts machen.
Server ist halt public, ne?
Gartenvideo,
also wieder YouTube-Trends, ja klar.
Muss.
Drei Millionen Views diesmal.
Der Attack-Heli geht ab.
Der Ons
jetzt müssen wir da ran hier.
Hä?
Da sind noch mehr, da sind noch mehr direkt vor unserer Nase.
Direkt vor unserer Nase sind noch mehr.
Pass auf, wenn wir nicht aufpassen, flanken die.
Wir bräuchten ein bisschen
Smoke oder so.
YOLO!
Jetzt werden sie gereckt. Jetzt werden sie richtig gereckt.
Sind die auf dem Dach?
Da oben sind sie drin.
Wir schießen jetzt noch so lange es irgendwie
geht.
Jetzt gehen wir raus. Das müssten wir haben.
Und jetzt lassen wir die erst gar nicht
mehr dazu kommen.
Schlecht, schlecht, schlecht, schlecht, schlecht, schlecht.
Hinlegen. Fuck! Um die Ecke.
Wo ist hier was?
Fuck him up, genau.
Fuck him up.
Was sagst du?
Jetzt haben wir es, jetzt haben wir es. Go, go, go.
Heschen.
Jetzt haben wir es überfahren, die Franzosen.
Oh!
Seite irgendwo.
Oh, die Runde habe ich aber nichts dazu beigetragen,
dass wir gewonnen haben.
Hey!
GG.
So, jetzt
Frage an euch.
Soll ich das Gartenstelz-Video, das 2-0er
Gartenstelz-Video heute Abend noch
freischalten oder erst morgen?
Ich meine, wenn ich das so frage, ich meine,
das sollte
recht klar sein, wie die Antwort
ausfällt, aber mal gucken.
Soll ich das heute Abend noch freischalten
oder
habt ihr eh keine Zeit mehr zu gucken? Man weiß
ja nicht. Kommt irgendwann mal
wieder was mit dem Kaboom? Ich denke schon.
Ja.
Gartenstelz, ja übrigens, danke Hexe, dass du
mitgespielt hast.
Lächerliches GG. Warum ist das
lächerlich? Das musst du mir jetzt mal erklären.
Das war doch wirklich mal eine gute Runde.
Spiel mal Dark Souls.
Willst du sehen, wie ich mich
aufrege, oder was?
Was? Und morgen Overwatch. Ja, morgen
tatsächlich Overwatch. Ich nehme was zur
Overwatch League auf.
Die ist jetzt ja durch, also die Preseason
ist jetzt ja durch. Mal
schauen wir noch an die, die da sind.
Habt ihr Overwatch League geguckt, oder juckt euch
Overwatch gar nicht?
Bitte BF1 nächstes Mal. Oh ne,
Battlefield 1 ist überhaupt nicht meins.
Ich mag Battlefield 1 nicht.
So, um nochmal ein bisschen epileptische Anfälle
zu provozieren.
Okay, so ungefähr so 1 zu 3.
So einen interessiert es 3 nicht.
Welche Programmiersprachen
kannst du? Boah,
äh, einige.
Das ist überlegentlich, dass ich jetzt irgendwas vergesse.
Fangen wir mal an. C-Sharp,
Javascript, na gut, Javascript,
das ist halt Javascript. C-Sharp,
Javascript, bisschen Python,
Ruby,
Rust,
Groovy,
das hab ich jetzt auch vergessen,
bisschen C++,
hab bestimmt noch einige
Dinger vergessen. Bash,
Shell,
bisschen PowerShell,
alle möglichen Dinger.
Meine Lieblingssprache ist allerdings
C-Sharp. Aber wenn ich
der größte Microsoft-Fan bin, aber
gefällt mir am besten.
Fragerunde bei dem Delay.
Moment, kann man das Delay rausmachen?
Muss ich mal gucken, ob ich das Delay jetzt entfernen kann.
Ich bin mal gespannt.
Ich bin mal gespannt,
was jetzt passiert, wo ich das Delay rausgenommen
hab.
Mojo HD.
Ja.
Weku Chat, Weku.
Gucken, ob das Delay jetzt weg ist.
Übrigens kennt einer noch das hier.
Warte mal.
Ich muss das mal kurz einblenden.
Hinzufügen,
Image,
Pictures,
Stream.
Kennt das noch einer?
Kennt ihr das noch?
In der Peking-Suppe.
So, Eax, wie sieht's denn aus?
Willst du jetzt noch eine Runde streamen?
Da kann ich dich nämlich hosten.
Jemand zugucken, der gut Overwatch
spielen kann.
Jetzt kommt aber der uralte Shit.
Mit welcher Software streamst du, OBS?
OBS, ähm, das einzige,
was ich mir jetzt überlegt hab, an meinem Streaming-Setup
noch zu verändern. Ich mein, man muss ja
sagen, es läuft wunderbar.
Jetzt, äh, seitdem
ich jetzt auch auf CPU-Encoding umgestellt hab,
720p,
60 FPS läuft ja wunderbar.
Ähm, ob ich mir noch
eine Elgato Capture Card besorgen soll,
die neue, die 4K Capture Card, die auch
120 FPS kann, oder
144 FPS,
ähm, und ich dann mit dem zweiten Rechner
streame. Ich hab hier zwei Rechner
stehen, quasi mal neun, wo es letztens ein Video
zugegeben hat, und,
und der alte noch.
Vielleicht mach ich das, mach ich das, aber eigentlich
ist es auferkellt. Auf der anderen Seite, ich hab den zweiten
eh immer an. So.
Wen könnten wir denn hosten?
Wen, wen hosten wir mal? Habt ihr
ne Idee? Habt ihr ne Idee,
wen könnte man denn jetzt hosten?
Wir hosten jetzt irgendeinen
Mercy-Main-Grill.
Wir haben ein paar deutsche, ein paar deutsche
Overwatch-Streamer am Start.
Ist Camille vielleicht online?
Nein.
Wen soll ich denn hosten? Macht, äh,
habt ihr irgendwie ne, irgendeine Idee?
Dafran spielt.
Oh, der
hat eh schon genug Zuschauer.
Komm, wir hosten, wir hosten
nen, nen super
Tracer-Spieler. Ist aber ein englischsprachiger
Stream. Bob Ross!
Hahaha. Switch,
Switch.
Wen, wen, wer wird jetzt gehostet?
Mal gucken. Hm.
Was? Ionek. Ah, den kenn ich,
den kenn ich. Das ist, das ist ein deutscher,
ein deutscher Overwatch-
YouTuber.
Aber, weiß ich nicht.
Spielt er gut?
Er ist Master. Okay, der muss ganz
gut spielen. Den hosten wir jetzt.
Den holt, den
hosten wir jetzt. Also, Leute.
Schön, dass ihr dabei gewesen seid.
Äh, was? Deutsch, alter.
Deutsch in 2K17.
Schön, dass ihr dabei wart.
Und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Stream. Mal gucken, was wir dann machen.
Wahrscheinlich wieder ein bisschen Overwatch, wenn ich's
geistig ertrage.
Bis denn.
Macht's gut. Und vielleicht gibt's
gleich noch Gartenstilz-Video. Bis denn.
Tschüss.